So, auf geht's!
Wollen wir uns das ganze mal ein paar Runden geben, wer?
Schauen wir mal.
Warum geht das nicht?
Kurz was gucken.
Will keine Account Infos leaken.
Ah.
Lul.
Ich hab grad mal geguckt.
Wir sind in der Que, aber ich glaub's nicht.
Ja, gut, dann müssen wir die Que kurz abwarten.
Tja, chat.
Also Runde Metro, das reicht wahrscheinlich schon wieder, was?
Hast du schon wieder keinen Bock mehr?
Ja, gut.
Dann warten wir mal in der Que, oder?
Oder was haben wir sonst noch?
Was haben wir noch für andere Server am Start?
Und hier, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Rush.
Rush only, Alter.
Guck mal hier, wie viele Server da voll sind.
Das ist doch nett.
Da stimmt doch was nett, äh.
Das Battlefield, äh, ja, oh, ja, und wie, und wie.
Only in Battlefield, äh.
EA Marketing Abteilung freut sich wieder.
Quertz cute.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, der, der und, und der, das Intro von Bad Company 1.
Aber der ist nice.
Das ist mein, das ist mein Lieblings Battlefield 7 Variante.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Keg wie?
Aber der ist gut.
Der ist richtig nice hier.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Und was ab, was auch nice ist der Battlefield 1, ähm, Intro 7 oder sowas.
Der ist auch poggers.
Der ist auch nice.
Ja, der, der, der ist auch nice.
Was hältst du vom MW2 Soundtrack?
MW2 Soundtrack ist der beste Call of Duty Soundtrack.
Guck mal, wolli mich verarschen?
Dead Game, warum bin ich immer noch in Position 3?
Alles klar, Sebaro.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, das beste, beste, beste Battlefield, Battlefield Team, äh, Anfang,
Anfang.
Ja, ja, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Jetzt, jetzt, gleich, gleich.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Bestes Intro.
Der ist, das, das Intro ist poggers, richtig geil.
Postchamp, alter.
Sag mal.
What the fuck?
Das Game is dead, warum komm ich nicht auf den Server drauf?
Also, aktuell, aktuell geht's gerade, guck mal hier, es sind 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12 Rush Server halbwegs besucht, ja.
Das geht.
Aber ich will halt, ich muss kurz warten, ich will einen von den 32, von den 32 Slots
haben.
Konnte man nicht irgendwo sehen, welche Leute auf dem Server sind und Ranks und so.
Ich brauch die Ranks der Leute, dass ich schön, schön, ich muss schön den Noob Server erwischen,
schön den Noob Server, bäm, bä, bä, bäm, wisst ihr, ja.
Hat man nicht mal, sag mal, bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben, hat man nicht mal
die Ranks der Gegner gesehen?
Man hat doch mal die Ranks der Gegner gesehen, oder?
Ja, ja, ich hab ein bisschen Delay, ich hab 30 Sekunden Delay, weil, das letzte Mal,
wo ich Battlefield gestreamt hab, haben mich sogar schon, das ist absolut totes Game, aber
zum Streamsnipen reicht's, ja, haben mich die Leute schon quasi über die halbe Map
abgeaimt.
Ähm.
Konnte man nicht mal?
Das ging, glaub, nur auf der Konsole, okay, ich glaub, ich suche jetzt echt einen anderen
Server, ich mein, what the fuck, ist hier los?
Ja, ja, in-game.
Gibt's Battlelog?
Ach, stimmt, genau, Better Battlelog.
Ja, tatsächlich, stimmt, ich erinnere mich ja wieder, genau, den Kram hatte man ja damals.
Runde vorbei, jetzt sollte Platz werden.
Auf welchem Server bist du, du X-Faite?
Auf welchem, auf welchem bist du?
Bist du auf dem, 187, oder bist du auf Cloverfield, oder bist du auf Dings, wo bist du?
Rush Grand Bazaar, ja, ja, ja, da versuche ich auch gerade zu joinen, da versuche ich
auch gerade zu joinen, aber das funktioniert nicht.
Äh.
What the fuck?
Ah, jetzt, okay, easy, warum, warum hab ich jetzt die Q übersprungen, das ist genau
der gleiche Server, dem ich vorher auch gejoint bin?
Wie block, der Ad-Blocker?
Ne, glaub ich nicht, der Ad-Blocker blockt hier nichts.
Guck mal, reload, all players, ne, sieht man echt nicht mehr, weiß nicht.
So, attack, auf gehts, Bambababam!
What the.
Wasenn des hier?
Oh ne, Battlefield, jetzt Taktik.
Aha, Moment, Moment, warte mal, ich bin, ich bin, ich muss Post Champen, Post Champ,
Wo sind wir? Wo sind wir? Moment, Moment.
Äh, äh, wir sind...
Warte mal. The fuck?
Ah, wir sind spawn-trapped Attacker.
Ah, jetzt versteh ich's.
Nee. Nee. Ah, nee!
Wir sind Attacker im Spawn der Gegner.
Moment, ich war grad...
Huge verwirrt war ich grad.
Huge verwirrt. Ich hab schon einen Weile nicht mehr gespielt.
Wir müssten die Runde doch eigentlich easy haben, oder?
Kommt mal 140 Tickets und wir sind noch direkt an den Gegnern dran.
What?
Ja, wie wär's mit Nameplate-Ladengame?
Konnte man hier durch? Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Nee, nee, ich glaub hier konnte man nicht.
Manche Sachen konnte man außen rumlaufen, aber ich glaub hier nicht.
Letzte Base, ja.
Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store,
zahlen die Kollektion barfick auf Sponsor.
Komm, rausgelaufen.
Raus.
Oh, jetzt vorbei, jetzt vorbei, jetzt vorbei.
Skip.
Wie, joint ihr jetzt grad alle den Server oder was, Chat?
Das wird übrigens, das wird für so krasses
Tryhard-Kram, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mach jetzt, ich mach jetzt
einfach Blackscreen und wechsle den Server.
Postchamp.
Oh, ich kann keine Memes einplanten.
Was ist hier los?
Warum nicht?
Ah, weil's Fullscreen ist.
Weil's Fullscreen und nicht Windowed
Fullscreen ist.
Also wir sind da grad ziemlich easy
as fuck. Da ist er, da ist er.
Ich komm mal zu dir rüber, oder du zu mir.
Können wir mal gucken, mal gucken, wie wir mal hinkommen.
Wird jetzt eh neu sortiert.
Spiele mal 64-Bahn-Rush-Bandamentick.
Oh, Bandamentick, oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Oh, jetzt kommt auch noch
Metro.
Warum so low?
Ehe, weil's so low ist.
Ich glaub, das ist, nee, ich glaub nicht, dass das
der zweite Account ist.
Ich hab ja auch total lang auf der Xbox gespielt.
Ich bin ja PC-Noob gewesen damals.
So, ich komm mal rüber zu dir.
So, Squad.
Switch.
Excellent.
Ah nee, ich bin schon drinne.
Sehr gut.
Poggers.
Ich seh's schon,
hier sind schon die Level 100er am Start.
Ich seh schon, das ist mit ultra, ultra, ultra
Tryhard-Krams klar.
Metro.
Battlefield 3 ist Metro, ist immer noch bestes Metro.
Okay, was macht der da?
Ah, ich wollte ihn gerade, ich wollte ihn auf dem
letzten Schuss bashen.
Aber nicht funktioniert.
Na, mal.
Wo, wo, wo, wo, wo sind die Gegner-Chymps?
NAAmChamp ist angesagt
Massive NAAmChamp
AlphaMap, ja so sieht's aus
Die Sound sind sogar, I get fucked in the ass over here
Die werde ich jetzt postchampen hier, komm her
Postchamp, postchamp
Postchamp, rechts noch einer. Bäm bä bä bäm, so muss das sein, jawoll
Twitch snoops
Oh fuck, meine links ist leer. Oh nein, ah, da sind ja noch mehr
Da liegt er, halb geklitscht in der Wand, alter
Oh nice
Ich brauche eine Waffe, haben wir, haben wir, hier, hier, da, die da, der Dude, der ist gut, den brauche ich, genau da, das Ding ist jetzt genau das wollte ich jetzt spielen
Genau das, die, das ist jetzt die Klasse, die wir brauchen um die Metro zu rushen
Die und nichts anderes, was hat denn der dabei? RPG und ein Tool
Oh, oh
Da kommt er um die Eck
Ich habe jetzt nicht mit so big brain Gegnern gerechnet, die auch mitspielen. Dafür habe ich jetzt wenigstens mal eine gute Klasse wieder
Heute würden die mit den Aussagen bestimmt den übelsten Shitstorm bekommen, ja
Und weil ich das übelst geil fand, die Sound-Samples, die werden übelst frei. I get fucked in the ass over here
Achtung, Achtung, post-champ, post-champ
Post-champ, Eckencamp, Eckencamp, post-champ. Das reiht sich sogar halbwegs
Oh nee, da hinten sind wir, ich habe es gesehen
Alter, kannst du mal springen?
Okay, okay, huge, huge, huge, huge, huge, huge
Legechamp machen wir jetzt. Legehenne, die Legehenne ist real
Äh, what?
Die Legehenne ist real und die Flank-Henne kommt auch noch
Alter, die Flank-Henne hat versagt, äh
Nice, Dankeschön
Was, was? Anzeige ist raus
Aim, aim, aim, aim
Hier kommen gleich welche
Ich höre hier 30 Billionen Gegner rumlaufen, Alter
30 Billionen Gegner rumlaufen, Alter. 30 Trillionen Gegners
Nein, nein, nein, bleibst du weg. Flashback des Todes, Legehenne. Oh, au, au, au
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Okay, ich höre immer noch mal, dass ich Gegner rumrenne. 11-1, so muss das sein, beste
Oh nee, jetzt kommt die ätzende Seite von Metro
Meinst du, wir kriegen es hin? Meinst du, wir kriegen es hin? Nein, schon wieder der Moritz
Der Moritz hat mich schon zweimal one-shot'ed um die Ecke, er
der moritz abmahnung ist raus
monka monac s alter gehst du f**k
ne ne ne
erstmal kurz aufladen
i get f**ked in the ass over hier
ok ok ok legehennen legehennen champ
ey und ich hab gedacht outplayed aber nix
oh nice nice so nice so nice so
ey what
ok da hat nur der kopf rausgeguckt aber das hat nicht gereicht
jetzt
NEIN
alter erschreck mich doch
oh da war von hinten einer ok ich habs verschissen
ey wir spielen ja mal richtig battlefields so wie es sein soll
kann ich mal blitz sterben
kommt her kommt her die kleinen pogge champs kommt her
NEIN
bf4 mit bf3 maps joah ich persönlich bugger battlefield 3 immer noch
am liebsten
ich mag herbattlefield 3 immer noch am liebsten
ich check überhaupt nicht wo hier irgendwas wo hier irgendwas geht alter
i get shot in the ass over hier
ja und ne runde suppressen und jetzt können wir drauf
nein wir können nicht drauf viel zu viele tickets ja ehrlich gesagt schon
a busy feel
aber dafür können wir doch das passt schon aber ich mein wir gehen da wirklich schnell
durch ne
aber die können immer noch die können immer noch uns bashen
die können uns immer noch bashen wenn sie es gescheit machen
achtung achtung flank champ flank champ
das mit der suppression ich muss auch im moment wir haben übelst unoptimiertes loadout
ich change mal ich change mal kurz loadout
ich mal kurz anti anti suppression raus
seh nix
die typo champen bestimmt pogge champen bestimmt da unten rum
okay ich komm mal rauf wo sind meine mates sind die da oben irgendwo
ne ne ne
unten war einer
direkt unter uns waren sie am start da ist was
vielleicht kommt er vielleicht kommt er hoch
macht er
ogos
und die schießen vom spawn rein glaube
jolo style jolo style oder doch nicht
ah fuck ich dachte ich mach den huge massive big brain play ja
mach ich nicht hätte sein können
kein big brain play
die sind wenn die gegner das gut machen sind die wirklich ziemlich schwierig hier
sind die über uns wo fällt hier was um
der typ steht immer hinter die zwei der stali und und der der moritz ey wie oft
dem ich diese runde schon in die s gefuckt haben
clever äußerst clever jetzt auf den dvd zu switchen aber der gelegenheit kann ich einfach
auch mal suppression rausnehmen und
monac s und ich nehme mal was brauchen wir denn was haben wir dann eigentlich für perks
lass mal kurz gucken dass das irgendwie zueinander passt
wir haben muni muni und suppression
ganz schön anstrengend mit stream ich glaube soviel stream style ist immer irgendwie wo
ging das jetzt noch mal gerade
oh leute wo kommen das park noch mal ändern oder was ja squad cover squad suppression
squad ammo haben wir schon squad sprint beste beste
jetzt passts wir müssen wir müssen mehr big big brain champ plays machen da war übrigens
die gegner ich habe es klären ich muss nur kurz waren kommt ihr raus
die gegner da oben alter battlefield please darf nicht
jetzt schreckt
massive plays am start hier
ich gehe dahin wenn ich einen diffusen hör
ja wenn man gewinnt macht das game immer bock
leute habt ihr es gesehen achter ping achter ping
achter ping
wo ist es ja bewerb face bewerbung ist raus
so ich muss mal chat gucken chat habe ich irgendwas übersehen
ich bin echt bei hitboxen gefixt
battlefield 3 kann jeder aim zieht man noch an mir
battlefield 3 ist da sehr nachsichtig was was hits angeht und so
und jetzt eine runde defender
nochmal attacker nee defend
was sind das hier das habe ich nie gesehen den teil von der map habe ich noch nie gesehen
guckt leute dahinten geht sam crossing los
lul nee nicht wirklich aber sieht so aus 22 ping viel zu hoch
ich muss mich mal kurz pissen alter piste schalte
mir ist gerade bisschen viel los hier ehrlich gesagt
ok battlefield retz geht mal wieder nicht
ich retze ich retze ich retze retz champ retz champ
retz champ poggers retz champ redicte der free fire retz champ
ok wo ist hier was ist hier noch irgendwo was
alter der retz train ist am start hier ich sag's euch
so muss es sein so nicht anders
oh leute ich sehe schon das gibt au au au das gibt base rape
da war doch eben was nein nein nein nein
glaub das gibt base rape nee ok gibt kein base rape weil die leute vorne
gestorben
stellz plant glaube es geht los
mehr wackeln please da unten war noch welche da unten war noch welche hab's gesehen
ja ich hab ein bisschen delay ein bisschen minimal minimales delay
ich kann bock auf dauer dauer stream snipe champ hab
ich brauch muni
ok wir können ein bisschen spotten munitions champ brauchen wir
ok jetzt kann ich sein scheiß nehmen
kit aufheben beste da hinten liegen noch irgendwelche zumindest hat er was rumgeschrien
ist grenade grenade blieb blieb ist es ein medic ach nee
ok die runde ist schon ein bisschen anstrengender
was das für eine pochern waffeln habe ich glaube nie gespielt
poggers champ glaubt ihr noch selbst nicht dass ihr hier durchkommt
ok qu leute chat wenn ihr eine muni kiste seht spammt mich mal voll
glaubt die pushen auf der anderen seite grad wieder
ich glaub die machen grad ziemlich ein push champ auf b
vor einer ammo kiste haben wir denn noch irgendwas
der typ der nut den brauche ich jetzt ja nein ammo kiste
das hat eine gescheite waffe warte mal war das mit g18 op in battlefield 3 oder battlefield
4 ok jolo jolo style die waffe brauche ich
von dem geb her jawoll
ok ok jetzt jetzt will ich wissen nein ich bin so ein nicer flank champ gemacht
so so so jolo style und überlebt und dann dumm von der seite gekillt er
kannst du bittest jedes nomen mit champ hinten dran sagen das problem dabei ist da müssen
wir erst mal wissen was ein nomen ist ich bin grammatik champ
oder kramat ich bin eher nicht grammatik champ
ist die runde wird er sogar richtig richtig poggers poggers champ
ist eine richtig richtig gute runde ach komm mal da ist der captain fang
ein spawn hinter mir wachs der hauptschule ab jetzt verrat doch nicht alles
oh iq champ äh moment falsche richtung
camp champ machen wir jetzt massive camp champ
ich glaube es nicht der typ der da sitzt er einfach schon der kommt an der seite
ich habe den gehört rechts und jetzt pikt er links die sau die sau pikt er
gerade zum falschen moment
vergiss es da ist mit ratz nix kann stells im schnee falsche richtung champ
klassiker ich hoffe du redest mit arbeitskollegen champ auch so immer
kommt doch mal mit wem ja es wäre nice wenn es ein ordentliches
battlefield mal wieder geben aber ich fürchte ich fürchte leute das hat sich
ausgebettel viel schämt so über welche seite kommen die kleinen die kleinen
pock champs denn vermute man links links ist
rättschamp haben wir jetzt jolo rättschamp
rättschamp da war er da war der rättschamp ich habe ihn gesehen
wo ist der rättschamp
achtung
what the hell
der ist der ist aus dem stand in in in tropschotter
über welche seite sind die denn jetzt hier gerade am pushtschampen
schwer zu rechts
pp gartschamp
i get fucked in the ass over here
wir müssen mal
die fußtschamp machen
hier geht gut was
wir klären jetzt erst mal rechts
im 16 16 spiel ich nicht
er schrecktschamp die drücken aber schon echt gut was bei montana pleck
digger ist es bei max chemp nee irgendwie sage ich sonst nie chemp aber
jetzt kann ich seit ich bettel viel angemacht habe alles
chemp spass chemp das gerade jetzt aber die gegner sind ganz schön aggressive
champs gerade aber ich glaube wir müssen rüber
glaube wir müssen rüber die sind ziemlich die sind ziemlich gut gut an b zur
am start
Okay, Flank-Cham, what the hell, nein, nein, so.
Das war mir zu viel gerade, zu viel um einmal.
Okay, B, B, B ist gut, B ist gut, nein, nicht sterben, nooo.
Ja stimmt, man musste in dem Game immer springen zwischendurch.
Sprung-Cham musste man machen, da war man schneller.
Was soll ich gerade machen, ich kann hier nicht raus.
Fuck, MonkaS, Alter, ich hab dich gesehen in der Ecke, Alter, Battlefield, please.
Fenster, Fenster-Cham, ah nice, die flanken gerade rum glaube ich, ich glaube die kommen
hier klar, nee, wow, knapp, sag ich doch die kommen von hinten.
Fuck, zu viel, zu viel, zu viel, der hätte ich nicht rumpushen sollen, das war low-prane,
richtig low-prane.
Nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben,
okay, excellent, weiß nicht von wo die, nein, nein, nein, sind die da oben noch, nee, oder,
ich blick gerade nicht durch, wo ist denn hier noch was, ah, rechts, linke Seite, okay,
ich, ich, ich sehe keinen Gegner, ist denn hier was, Gegner-Cham, ah, da oben, Suppression-Cham,
habt ihr das gesehen, halber Magazin durchgesprayt durch den Kopf, fuck, spielst du auch Warzone,
vereinzelt, vereinzelt mal, ganz vereinzelt, in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr, ah, ich trau
mich da nicht hin, nee, nee, nee, da kann ich nicht hin, ich, ich mach mal kurz Aim-Cham,
ich will einfach nur wissen, wo der Gegner ist, wenn er auf den schießt, okay, ich hab
keine Ahnung von wo genau, ich muss mal kurz verpissen, sag mal, irgendwie geht grad echt
gar nichts rein, dann geh ich noch, bam, bam, bam drauf, PKP, beste, einfach in eine Richtung
Spray-Cham machen, ich sterb, ich sterb, ich sterb, please, please, please, please, okay,
alles klar, Battlefield Big Brain-Cham, okay, okay, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Massive
Big Brain, Big Brain-Flank, wir machen jetzt Big Brain-Flank, Leute, ich sag's euch, Massive
Big Brain-Flank, wo ist der Gegner, bam, okay, tot, Cham, nein, bam, ganz schöner Leck,
wir müssen die hier mal wegpushen, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob da rechts einer war, ich
will die rechts rauspushen, wir müssen hier rauspushen, genau, genau, genau, rauspush-Cham,
das war so ein nicer Flank-Cham gewesen, der wär nice gewesen, hätte ich den noch erwischt,
hätte ich den noch gekriegt, ey, das ist so, teilweise gute Spieler, teilweise sind Twitch-Noobs,
aber hey, ich hab auch noch ein halbes Jahr oder so, ein Jahr oder ewig noch mal Battlefield
gespielt, ich bin auch Kack-Noob, da geh ich nicht durch, oh, oh, oh, der Captain Peng,
Bunn ist raus im Chat, sag ich dir, mit der Shotgun, Shotgun-Bugshot, Instant Bunn, heute
noch 9 Tickets, wir dürfen's jetzt nicht verscheißen, weil jetzt pushen sie alle,
jetzt machen sie alle Push-Cham, ich mach mal selbstlosen Objective-Bewacher, guck,
guck, guck, Leute, ich hab's euch gesagt, die machen Push-Cham, selbstlose Objective-Bewacher,
nicht auf Objective-Play, Leute, ey, nein, WTF, timeoutet den doch nicht, das war ein
Witz, nein, das ist nicht übertreiblich, Alter, lull, ich glaub, du kannst wieder join,
du bist wieder end-timeoutet, ich war's nicht, tolles Gameplay, nein, danke, das ist halt
auch ein Game, wo ich ein bisschen schon gespielt hab, naja, naja, ich sag nix, sag ich, du kannst
Shotgun spielen, so viele Shotgun spielen, das sind so die üblichen, die üblichen Low-Brain-Flames,
okay, jetzt wird gepusht, Leute, jetzt wird gepusht, was das Zeug hält, ich sag's euch,
Poggers Push-Cham, oh, oh, die Posi sagt, wie ich hier grad lang renn, das ist ultra
Low-Brain, naja, guck, guck, guck, da sind die Gegner schon, bam, okay, Defender-Cham,
und jetzt, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nice, ne, Hallo, Hallo, Battlefield, Hitbox, please, MonkaS,
ach, da ist ne Wand, da ist ne Wand, da kann man grad durchschießen, oder wie, lull, Alter,
WTF?! Guckt's euch an! Die Battlefield Champs!
Ich muss mal kurz hier rüber champen.
Lass mich in Ruhe! Ok, wo ist er? Gehst du fort? So nicht!
Ja, nice! Flankerino gibt's jetzt. So ist das nice! Man braucht ordentliche
Teammates, so muss es sein. I get fucked in the ass over here. Fuck, jetzt wirklich.
Richtig weggesprayt haben sie mich. Wo sind wir hier? Alter, wo stellst du...
Ah, big brain stellts play. What?! Ich bin prefired um die Ecke gerannt,
Alter! Was ist das? Prefired um die Ecke gerannt, hat die nicht interessiert.
Ok, ich hätte vielleicht rein aimen sollen, aber trotzdem. Fields Batman. Wir brauchen
das, ich guck später mal. Ich muss erstmal im Scoreboard wieder Top 3, sonst fühle ich
mich zu Pepega. Achtung, zack! Ganz schön schwierig, weil so viele support champs am
Start sind. Ok, ok, big brain, jawoll. Hier, hier ist gut, hier ist gut. Gute Pose,
gute Pose. Alter! Lass mal kurz regnen, regnen, regnen. Hell yeah! Kokona! Ah, fuck. Ey,
ne Megüde, ey. Das ist grad ganz schön... So, nicht laggy, so rumge... Oh, oh, oh. Ich
bin, ich bin depth champ, richtiger depth champ, warum ich da um die Ecke gegangen bin.
Zu, zu viel, zu viel, will unbedingt Kill machen. Oh, ey. Die Farmen, die Farmen hier
killst, kills of doom. Komm mal hier, nur 6er. Das ist ja, das geht ja nicht. Das geht
ja so nicht. Exzellent. Ich mach jetzt Legehenne. Beste Legehenne aller Zeiten, mach ich jetzt.
Und jetzt aimen wir sie einfach. Jetzt wollen wir einfach aim, aim in eine Richtung und
dann, und dann abdrücken. Oh, so muss es sein. Camp champ. Der Klassiker. Du bist zu gierig,
so siehts aus, ja. Aber nur so macht man noch die Top, die Top Kills Gameplays. Guck, auch
dass ich jetzt losrenne, ist dumm. Ich hätte eigentlich warten müssen, ob da nicht noch
vielleicht Nachzügler um die Ecke champt, so wie der da. What? Achso. Geht, der lebt
noch einer, einer lebt noch links. Wallbang. Lul. Der ist noch links, der ist noch der
dude. Keep on moving, keep on moving. Ah, nice. Die allerbeste Legehenne ist das. Und,
also, beste Rättshenne und beste Legehenne. Und beste Assaultchamp, äh. Okay, okay,
okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. Jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds kritisch. Kritischer Henne, äh.
War das nicht Apokalyptoret, der irgendwas von kritischer Hase immer gesagt hat?
Kritischer Hase, riecht, riecht stumm eigentlich. Ich mach jetzt die ganz, die, die geschwindeste
Legehenne aller Zeiten. Oh, huge place, huge place. Und jetzt nix wie weg hier. Achtung,
holo Rätts, holo Rätts. Bam. Ah, nee. Rätts, Rätts Deal hier. Da sitzt noch was. Ach nee,
das ist ne Tischkante. Lul. Das war ne Tischkante, ich dachte das ist ein gegnerisches Gewehr.
Okay, ich mach Aimchamp, die kommen nämlich zurück, die kommen zurück. Ich sag's euch,
dass die zurückkommen. Wisst ihr, ich wusste doppeltes auch noch. Bam. Ich wusste, dass
die zu, oh nee, fuck. Ich wusste, dass die zurückkommen. Das war klar, die haben, die
haben da vorne Spawnchamp gemacht oder sowas in der Richtung. Und dann haben sie gehört,
dass das M-Comp liegt und dann war klar, dass die umdrehen. Oh, nicht sterben, nicht sterben,
nicht sterben, nicht sterben. Survivechamp. Ja, nice. Ein nicer Survivechamp. Oh, oh, oh,
der lebt. Chat, ich glaub ich muss noch mehr Champs sagen, oder? Noch zu wenig. Zu wenig
Champs. Champs per second. CPS. Warum eigentlich Legehennen? Weil ich das mit dem Kabum irgendwann
mal den ganzen Tag erzählt habe und seitdem, seitdem ist M-Comp liegen Legehennen. Okay,
der Fatal macht das, Jens, und ich mach Up-Aim-Stills. Hallo? Suppression-Champ? Okay, der kommt
hier hinten lang, der kommt hier hinten lang. Okay, das war jetzt nicht mehr zu rechnen,
dass die dann von hinten kommen, quasi aus unserem Laufweg. Weiß nicht, ob wir hier
rein spawnen sollen, die Ecke sackt ehrlich gesagt. Yolo-Champ. Campen die hier ab? Campen
die hier ab? So, und jetzt machen wir Container-Champ. Äh, Moment, das geht noch von der anderen
Seite, ne? Weil beste Posey, beste Posey, da macht keiner was hier. Das Ding ist unzerstörbar,
keine Granaten, kein Panzer, nichts kann dieses Ding kaputt machen. Beste Camp-Posey hier
auf der ganzen Map, dieser kack Container. Um nicht zu sagen Container-Champ. Sag mal,
ich bin, ich bin verwirrt. Wo ist denn hier was? Mein Kill, nein.
Nein, ich kack den Hub, ich hab da nicht gerade gedacht, dass da, dass da der Gang ist. Okay,
komm den Letzten kriegen wir doch jetzt auch noch hin. Nein. Da isser. Okay, lege Hände,
lege Hände. Fuck, shit. Habe ich eigentlich gedacht, das kriege ich noch irgendwie, aber
da war zu viel, da war zu viel los. Okay, bin wir der Erste. Dann, dann ist, hab ich
meine Pflicht getan hier. Oh, der Fatal ist im Panzer, exzellent. Ich warte bis jetzt
vielleicht einer von meinem Team aussteigt oder so, dann kann ich dann direkt reinspornen.
Oder ich gehe, ich könnte auch als, als Engi dahin, könnte ich rappen, Reparaturschamp
machen. Okay, ne. Gibt keine Reparaturschamps. Ich kann aber einfach bei dem gleich reinspornen.
Okay. Ich spawn bei dem. Remax, moin. Ich, wie gesagt, ich kann grad nicht so richtig
Chat gucken. Das ist, das ist grad, das war ein Brain zu Low Chat zu gucken. Oh, die fallen
ganz schön um da vorne, wir müssen glaube ich hier irgendwie mal gucken, dass wir. Oh,
ein A-Aim-Aim-Champ. Ich darf, ich darf nicht so viel spammen. Ich hab mich da so dran gewöhnt,
dass man spammen kann. Dabei kann man auf die Range gar nicht gut spammen. Das sprayt
zu viel. Okay, Granate. Jawoll. Jetzt muss er weg, jetzt muss er weg. Muss er weg.
Granate-Champ. Okay, hier kommt nix, hier kommt. Ey, der Tonnenchamp. Oh ne, ne, ne, fuck, fuck,
fuck, fuck. Monarch-S. Fuck, ich dachte ich krieg ihn noch. Fuck, ich dachte ich krieg
ihn noch, komm noch um die Ecke. Shit. Vielleicht krieg ich nen Ratschamp, die sind ja noch nicht
dran. Nice, nice, nice, nice. Nice. Easy. Nice Runde. Bam. Huge Teamplay. Nice, nice,
nice. So muss das sein. So muss das sein. Pro-Motion. Sergeant of Master Sergeant Extreme. Ach,
übrigens, Chat ist die Bitrate, okay. Wie sieht, wie sieht das aus, das Game? Ich hab
auf 7900 gestellt. 1080p. Schauen wir mal, wie es aussieht. Ahja. Sieht, sieht okay
aus, denke ich. Ja, nice, nice Runde. Guckt euch das mal an hier. Der Fatal ging ab, du
hast Panzerstellts gemacht, oder? Oh. Okay, wir machen jetzt offensiv. Okay,
wir machen jetzt offensiv-Champ. Offensiv-Champ of Doom. Okay, das war's für heute, ich hoffe
das war's für heute. Okay, das ist ne fiese Pose, ich geb euch zu. Der Feuerbird, da ging
mir Feuer schon auf den Sack. Okay, der stirbt nicht. Okay, keine Ahnung, was das jetzt ist.
Okay, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt, Flank, Flank, Flank des Todes. Poggers-Champ. Nein,
das war doch verschissen. Flank-Champ verschissen. Warum muss das sich auch jetzt umdrehen?
Okay, wir müssen jetzt die andere Seite machen. Nein, nein, nein. Deswegen magisch Battlefield
3, die Maps sehen erstmal richtig dumm aus, sind aber übelst durchdacht was Punkte und
so angeht, auch wo man, wo man hin kann. Gucken, wenn jetzt hier einer rauskommt, kriegt
er gleich. Weg-Spray-Champ. Okay, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo. MonkaS, was ist hier los?
Was ist hier los? Jawoll, der Fädel räumt auf. Wie, die haben gelegt? Wie konnten die
da Legehähne machen? Wie haben die denn da die Legehähne gemacht? Oh, wir entschärfen
noch. Oh, Diffuse, Diffuse. Nein. Fuck. Hätte, hätte, hätte, hätte hinhauen können. Wartet
mal, Leute. War das das Game mit der OP G18? Moment. Ah, excellent. Beste. OP-Champ. Blöd,
blöd, blöd. Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Alles klar, alles klar, alles klar. Huge, massive
Plays. Poggers Plays, Leute, müsst ihr mal zugeben, ha? Ah, Mist. Rex. Oh, die Rex, genau.
Oh, die Rex war auch so geil. Die Rex war auch richtig huge. Okay, die müssen wir stürmen.
Battlefield 3 ist so ein Ding. Man verliert es nicht, da ist noch einer drin, by the way.
Man verliert es nicht. Einmal Battlefield 3, immer Battlefield 3. Oh, Aua. Okay, das
war dumm. Richtig Low-Brain-Aktion. Das Dumme ist, man darf nicht komplett wippen, weil
wenn man komplett wippt, dann ist halt offen, was halt sagt. Wir sind jetzt schon ziemlich
nah dran. Oh, shit. Okay, das ist gar nicht richtig zu verteidigen. Okay, wir machen
jetzt mal den Randstelz-Champ. Nee, nee, nee, keine Chance. Hätte sein können. Aber
die Rex, Rex müsste ich echt mal wieder spielen. Oh, jetzt. Nein. War da nicht noch einer?
War nicht Bad Company 2? Nee, ist auf einem Level, ist echt auf einem Level. So, jetzt
müssen wir hier Ausfallstelz machen in die Richtung und hoffen, dass die Gegner das
nicht checken. Ja, ich laufe jetzt hier nicht raus, Battlefield Boys und Girls. Ich laufe
hier nicht raus, das kannst du vergessen. Ihr müsst kommen, ich nicht. Ihr müsst kommen,
ja, ja. Auf, auf. Ich bewege mich nicht. Ich, ich aime mir hier. Ah, fuck. Okay, mehr
konnte ich jetzt echt nicht machen. Guck mal hier. Das ist ja halb, halb Spanien, ey,
oder sonst was. Das ist ja voll. Okay, der hat gute, der hat einen guten Positions. Okay,
da ist jetzt Polen echt offen gerade. Oh hier, wo ist der Fatal? Zu dem müssen wir. Wobei
ehrlich gesagt, die Pose von dem Dude hier, ach, ganz nett. Alter, was ist denn da los,
ey? Alter, habt ihr gesehen? Da aimen mich fünf Leute ab. Fuck. Okay, ich bin hier,
habt ihr gesehen? Da aimen mich fünf Leute ab. Fuck. Okay, schnell, schneller, ein schneller
Champ. Oh, Diffuse Champ, Diffuse Champ, Diffuse Champ, Diffuse Champ. Exzellent.
Big Brain. Für, für das Team hier, Diffuse. Ich hab Angst. Ah, shit. Okay, okay, der ist
down. Gut, gut, gut, gut. Ich warte, ob er gerätzt. Oh nee, von der Seite. Oder? Nein,
ich wollte gerade, ich wollte gerade den Defi rausholen. Gerade wollte ich den Defi holen.
Guck's euch an. Iron Sides, links, rechts, links, rechts, links, rechts. Der Typ ist
auch geil. Alter, der Schneiberman hier. Okay, okay, okay, wir sollten mal auf der
anderen Seite abchecken, dass da nichts durchkommt. Okay, okay. Jawoll, jetzt haben wir euch.
Jetzt haben wir euch. Kleinen Pfötzchen. Oh nein. Oh, wir sind auf Twitch, hab ich
vergessen. Hab ich nicht gesagt. Jetzt sind sie dran. Au. Ah. Die Wand ist einfach mal
weg. Die Wand ist weg. Wandchamp. Das Spiel hatte ich rausgeworfen. Warum das denn? Find
ich aber nicht fair. Abmahnung an Server-Admin ist raus. Oh, die kommen gleich. Ich trau mich
hier nicht alleine vor. Ich mach mal abwarte, Champ. Siehste, siehste, siehste, war besser.
Ist hier was? Ich seh nix. Auf Twitch darfst du nicht Blind-Playthrough sagen, ich weiß.
Das ist Monkathos. Das andere darf ich sagen. Okay, ich glaub, die haben wir ganz gut.
Hier ist nix mehr. Hier ist nix mehr. Ich glaub, die haben wir. Ich glaub, die haben
wir. Nice, nice, nice, nice. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wollen wir da vor? Wollen wir
uns trauen? Trau-Champ? Das ist doch ne gute Idee. Wo spawnen die eigentlich? Spawnen die
wieder direkt im Spawn oder spawnen die? Fuck Leute, ich kann euch nicht holen. Ich kann
euch nicht holen. Da bin ich selbst down. Da oben ist noch einer. Was? Nein. Die war
Schafe hat ihn verraten. Okay, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen hier. Alter, was ist das hier
für ne Gespämme? Massive Spamzor. Guckt euch meine Granatengespämme an. Das ist doch
nicht mehr normal. Aber das ist gut. Die sollen sich ruhig mal hier aufreiben. Das
ist halbe Team. Das hat sich richtig gelohnt, wisst ihr das? Die haben sich gerade mit 8
Leuten um 3 Leute gekümmert. In der Zwischenzeit haben die nix gemacht. Das hat sich wirklich
gelohnt. Und jetzt können wir sie hier abfangen. Weil hier kommen die jetzt ja nicht so einfach
durch. Weil generell ist Bazaar hängen geblieben. Auf Rättsplitz. Nee, gibt's nicht. War nicht
Player? Doch, doch, doch, doch. Es war maximal 32 Player. Sag mal, ist der die ganze Runde
da? Kann das sein? Ist der die ganze Runde da? Ist das im Bereich das Mögliche? Okay,
ich muss mal andere Seite kurz protekten. Wobei. Bin mir da nicht so sicher. Vielleicht bleibe
ich auch hier. Ja. Medi, Medi, Medi. Achtung. Big brain play. Jawoll. Flank. Nice. Ah, shit.
Ich dachte, ich komm noch weg. Zu gierig, Leute. Zu gierig. Zu gridi. Moment. Kopf einzieht,
aber das ist eine Top-Pose, die wir haben. Paar Leute links, paar Leute rechts. Habt
ihr die Rakete gesehen? Also die Rakete ist direkt an meinem Kopf vorbeigeflogen. Habt
ihr das gerade gesehen? Ich hab noch nie in meinem Battlefield Leben so genau eine Rakete
gesehen. MonkaS. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Oh nein, Mörserstelz. Muss weg. Hat sich aus Mörserstelz. Och,
oh, oh, oh. Okay, ich muss aufs Dach. Ich muss aufs Dach. Dachbeste-Posie. Dachbeste-Posie,
wenn die hier durchpushen. Kommst du her? Ich seh nix. Hier, Dachbeste-Beste-Beste-Poggers-Posie
hier. Ich seh nix. Spam nicht so viel da rein. Okay, den hab ich zu spät gesehen. Der ist
da links irgendwo. Okay, vielleicht können wir Flankerino machen hier rum. Vielleicht,
vielleicht, vielleicht. Ah, schön, schön, schön, schön. Okay, ich kann jetzt pieken.
Der Typ retzt. Sehste, sehste? Predicted. Der Typ retzt. Der Typ retzt wieder. Und die
nächsten retzten. Oh neun, da kommt der Tank. Da kommt der Panzmann. Der Panzmann ist am
Start. Ich musste weg. Nein, die haben gelegt. Legehennet. No. Kriegen wir das? Ah, wir haben
schon Diffusord. Nice. Exquisite Place. Alter, Monarch-S, Monarch-S. Ey, was ist hier los?
Monka, Monka-Giga, Monka-Giga. Okay, ich retz dich, Alter. Ich retz dich. Bam. Und weg.
Gleich haben wir's, Leute. Gleich haben wir Windchamp. Oh ne, die sterben auf der anderen
Seite, okay. Kurz hier aimen, ja, ab aimen. Die, die pushen jetzt. Das ist wie in Overwatch.
Das ist wie in Overwatch. Die pushen, die pushen dann immer noch mal zum Schluss wie
verrückt raus. Oh. Bam. Äh, sind jetzt wieder mehr Spieler in Battlefield 3, seit man es
kostenlos als Prime-Kunden spielen kann. Ja. Ja. Sind jetzt 10 Server voll oder so. Also,
es gibt ja schon die ganze Zeit viele Server, aber es sind meistens nur zwei Stück belegt.
Der eine davon ist 48-Player-Demoman-Peak oder 64-Player-Demoman-Peak und das andere
ist, ich glaub, Rush-Klassik oder so. Also, man kann das noch gut spiegeln, aber. Das
Schöne ist, ich kann mir dann später aus dem Stream vielleicht sogar ein paar Gameplays
extracten. Man war ja ein paar ganz gute Sachen dabei. Vielleicht nicht das komplette Gameplay,
aber mal immer so ein paar Clips. GG Maxchamp. Schau wieder. Moment, ist der Server Metro
und Grand Bazaar Only? Kann das sein? Oder konnte man da irgendwie voten? Aber ohne Scheiß,
ich wechsle die Server nicht, solange es gut läuft. Das ist Failchamp. Das ist taktisch
gar nicht so clever, was wir hier machen, aber da ist schon der Erste. Ab Aimchamp. Jetzt
werden wir erstmal nice eingesmoked, aber die rechnen nicht mit meinen Q-Drück-Skills.
Ich kann einfach durch den Smoke aimen, durch den Smoke Q drücken. Alter, Aimchamp. Ich
schätze dich. Easy. YOLO Mode. Könnt ihr mal sterben, please? Könnt ihr mal sterben?
Was ist hier los? Ich falle nicht mehr um. Hab ich Damage Debuff? Damage Debuff. Okay,
Battlefield Logik. Battlefield Logik. Nein, fuck von der Seite. Da hab ich nicht drauf
geguckt. Man kann nicht überall hingucken, aber wisst ihr was, was mir an Battlefield
Toden und versus Call of Duty Toden. Call of Duty Toden, stirbst du an irgendeinem Bullshit
und bist mega abgefuckt und Battlefield Tode ist so, ja fuck, ich bin zu dumm in die richtige
Richtung zu gucken. Zumindest in dem Battlefield. Es hat mich ja nichts Bullshit-mäßiges getötet,
es hat mich jetzt einfach gegrillt, dass ich nicht in die richtige Richtung geguckt hab
und ich hätte eigentlich schon mal Spawn checken können, weil es eigentlich dumm
da ich es nicht gemacht hab. Weiß übrigens nicht, ob das ein Coo...
I get fucked in the ass over here.
Warum bin
ich jetzt in diesem Moment aufgestanden? Ich bin in diesem Moment aufgestanden und
konnte nicht aim, das war mega lucky, äh, oder unlucky für mich. Danke schön, nice.
Oh, oh, oh fuck, ich hab ja vergessen, dass die von hier kommen können. Monarch, Monarch
S, lasst mich, oh fuck, ich war fast weg, ich war fast weg. Plus RNG, Alter. Ah nee, das
gibt's ja auch nicht mehr. Alles wurde entfernt von Twitch mittlerweile.
Da ist was, ich hab die Waffe gesehen um die Ecke. Der Typ ist hochgerannt. Nein, nein,
nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Das war, ach stimmt, das war Feuer, was mich in der U-Bahn gebashed
hat. Ach ja, stimmt. Dankeschön, nice, nice. Wie, das waren zwei? Habt ihr den zweiten
gesehen? Habt ihr den zweiten gesehen? Ich hab den nicht gesehen. Okay. Ha, Spray-Champ.
Ach guck mal, da kommt der Stell-Spot links, habt ihr das gesehen? Nein, der, der, der
Bot, der Bot stellt's zum M-Kub, guckt's euch an. Oh, jetzt. Oh, das ist aber mutig
hier, Leute. Das ist mutig, was ihr hier macht. Twitch, mutig. Die Posi ist echt mutig. Oh-oh-oh,
fuck noob-mate. Okay, das M-Kub kriegen sie defused. Blast RNG ist weg. Ähm, ich bin
mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, warum Blast RNG weg ist. Ich glaub, der Typ, der hat irgendwas.
War das nicht, dass der seine Frau geschlagen hat oder sowas? Das kann jetzt sein, dass
ich voll falsch liege und verwechsel. Ah, huge. Big, big brain-mate. Okay, wir machen
jetzt Poggers-Push, Poggers-Push. Wisst ihr was? Das ist ja mal seit Ewigkeit eine ordentliche
Battlefield-Runde, wo die Leute sich auch mal ordentlich supporten und sowas. Da kommt
gleich der andere Dude rum. Äh, meine Fräse. Was ist hier los? Anstrengend, Champ. Okay,
gute Posi, gute Posi. Äh, äh, Moment, wo sind wir, wo sind wir? Fuck, wo sind wir,
wo sind wir? Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Da müssen wir durch, da müssen wir durch. Hätte ich
das mal, hätte ich das mal ein bisschen mehr Big Brain gespielt? Alle down. Fuck, dabei
war das so ein nicer Push. Da kommt gleich der andere Dude. Fuck, von der Seite, ich
habe ihn nicht gesehen. Ich bin doof gewesen. Alter, ist das Oldschool-Feeling? Ja, ich
hoffe mal. Aber das geht auch nur so gut, weil gerade Prime-Noobs am Start sind. Wobei
der Server schon ziemlich voll ist jetzt auch mit etwas besseren Leuten. Okay, jetzt ist
der Push. Der Push ist dead, Leute. Dead Push. Dead Game, Dead Push. Push, Champ. Zu viele
gute Gegner. Okay, hier kommt's nicht durch. Das ist wirklich Metro-suckbar-massive, was
das angeht. Also, wenn du hier festhängst. What the fuck ist hier wieder los? Wirst du
sonst wie gehitten? Ah nee, Moment, war der Typ hinter mir? Okay, Fatal, Fatal, gute
Posey, gute Posey, eine nice Posey. Oh, perfekt. Alter, was ist denn hier los? Ich kann da
nicht hin, ich muss euch spawnen lassen bei mir. Hier geht ja mal nix. Und ich sehe auch
kein Gegner. Ha! Erwischt. Pogchampos. Pogchampo. Boah, MonkaS. Alter, was ist hier alles drin?
Das ist ja halb China eingewandert gerade. Oder ausgewandert, je nachdem, wie man sieht.
Ey, die Hälfte der Battlefield-Population sitzt hier gerade an B. Da ist noch einer
drin. Okay, ich wall-bange mal ein Nate um die Ecke. Nate wall-bangs. Okay, ich bin
hier. Fuck, den hätte ich erwischt. Hätte ich den gehabt, hätte ich den gehabt, hätten
wir sie jetzt richtig in die S. Okay, aber das müsste retzbar sein. Das müsste, ich
müsste retzbar sein, glaube ich. Oh, Alter. Oh, ein bisschen Gegner, oder? Nee. Oh fuck.
Alter, das ist, das ist nicht normal die Action gerade. Das ist, das ist absolut unnormal.
Es ist nicht, es ist, es ist massive unnormal. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist ja, das macht
mein Brain nicht mit. Alter, mein Brain ist, ist, ist zu, zu lauter für. Ah, mein Brain
ist, ich mach, das kannst du vergessen. Die Gegner fahren sich ja übelst kaputt gerade
an uns. Okay, okay, jetzt noch mal ordentlicher Push, ordentlicher Push noch mal. Noch mal
Push-Champ. Oh, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, Push-Champ. Ah, fuck. Push, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein. Zu knapp. Wo sind wir hier gelandet? Sonstwo. Also das M-Com, wenn man da stacked
ist, ist wirklich krass. In the corp, ey. I get fucked in the ass over here. Keck, was
war das? Ah, einen hab ich erwischt, aber die haben, guck mal, die hatten die Ecke
von links und die Ecke von rechts. Okay, wenn das nicht reicht. Kollege, so nicht,
so nicht, so nicht. Battlefield 4 würde ich mich jetzt auflegen auf, oh nee, würde ich
es auflegen auf der Ecke? Mega knapp. Okay, mal kurz. Nee, nee, keine Chance. What the
fuck? Okay, du kommst hier nicht raus. Keine Chance, ey. Keine Chance. Oh, nice, nice,
ganz chill. Okay. Ah nee, da drüben sind auch schon ganz viel. Wir kommen, wir kommen
einfach nicht vorwärts. Wir kommen einfach nicht vorwärts, ja. Ich muss, wir müssen
irgendwie, wir müssen irgendwie Pushchamp machen. Okay, nice, nice Pushchamp. Okay,
ich mach mal kurz Spawn Beacon, ich kann mich eh nicht bewegen. Ah, ah, ich seh's nicht,
ich seh' die Nate nicht. Wenn man die Nate nicht sieht, stirbt man nicht an der Nate.
Genau, beste Taktik. Metro ist ein Clusterfuck ohne Ende. Okay, jetzt. Pfff, ha, scheiße,
man. Wir brauchen Smoke, wir brauchen Smoke, ja, wir brauchen Smoke. Excellent, excellent.
Smoke, ich switch, ich switch auf Smoke. Wo ist denn Smoke überhaupt? Loadout? Accessories?
Nee, Moment. Nee, Secondaries. Nee, nee, hier, Smoke. Anstatt Defi Smoke, nee, anstatt,
da. Das ist Feuer? Kann das sein, dass ich gar kein Smoke hab? Ist das Smoke? Das, das
ist, das ist kein Smoke, oder? Bin, ich bin zu noob für euch, ich weiß, ich weiß nicht,
wie man Smoke ausequipt, ja. Ich hab's vergessen, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie man Smoke equippt.
Statt Medikit. Ja, hab ich ja probiert. Smoke, Smoke Champion.
Ich hab's vergessen, ich weiß nicht, wie man Smoke ausequipt, ja. Ich hab's vergessen,
ich weiß nicht, wie man Smoke ausequipt, ja. Ich hab's vergessen, ich weiß nicht, wie man
Smoke ausequipt, ja. Alter, was ist hier los? Ey, ich bin, das ist zu... Mein Kopf macht
es nicht mit. Mein Kopf ist zu low-brain dafür. Alter, mein Kopf ist, ich krieg's nicht hin.
Okay, Lege-Champ. Nein, nein, wir haben's gelegt, wir haben's gelegt. Ich weiß es nicht,
die Lege-Henne war raus. So close. Die Lege-Henne war auf dem Weg und ich kam nicht an.
Nein, nein. Ich fass es nicht.
Ich hab... Nochmal Metro halt schnell aus. Ich glaub, es kommt noch mal... Es kommt noch
mal ein Metro Defender, oder? Schöner Lose. Exzellent. Exquisite Loss. Okay, das ist die
Rückrunde, die spielen wir noch. Dann gehen wir irgendwo auf den anderen Server oder so.
Das krieg ich jetzt... Das halt ich nicht aus. Okay, Moment. Wie equippt man hier noch
mal Smoke? Ich will jetzt keinen Smoke equippen. Okay, klick auf das... Kann das sein, dass
ich Smoke nicht freigeschaltet hab? Oder ist das Smoke? Bin da zu dumm für, oder ist
das schon zu lange her? Wenn du viel rein musstest du auch voll gleich instant am Start
sein, weil die Leute hier schon ranrushen. Guckt's euch an. Und instant Pogchamps am
Start. Instant kleine Pogchamps am Start hier. Warum kann ich die nicht spotten? Gameville
nicht. Nope. Kein Spot. Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz hier Campchamp machen. Campchamp,
weil ich wusste, dass die hier rumkommen. Oh, der lebt noch, oder? Lebt der noch? Okay,
der lebt noch. Nee, der lebt nicht. Oh, Fatal bist du weg? Ah nee, du bist noch da. Okay,
aber die haben mich voll geguckt. Du bist weg. Ja, ist klar. Voller Magazin im Kopf, juckt
uns nicht, Yolo. Ist uns egal, ist uns egal. Juckt uns alles nicht, ist egal. Wir müssen,
wir müssen auf B, wir müssen auf B. B-Champ, B-Champ. What the fuck? Battlefield, please.
Die kommen gleich von der anderen Seite. Fuck. Okay, da kannst du nicht viel machen. Muss,
man muss probieren. Ah shit. Ja, ich würde, ich, also wie gesagt, die Rückrunde spielt
da muss ich mal eine andere Map spielen. Das hallt schnell aus. Nein, nein, nein, ich sterbe.
Okay, die machen jetzt Push-Champ von hier. What the fuck? Ah, jetzt wird die M16 rausgeholt.
Verstehe, verstehe, jetzt wird die M16 rausgefilmt. Jetzt kommt die M16. Da wird die M16 rausgeholt.
Einfach mal jetzt. Wenn nichts mehr geht, dann kommt die M16. So habe ich das gern.
Wenn nichts mehr geht, dann kommen die M16. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich, ich meine, ich darf das
sagen, ich spiele nur M416, ja. Und M416 ist okay, aber M16 nicht. Habe ich jetzt einfach
mal gerade so defined. Alter, was ist denn hier los? Ich sehe ja mal was, wo hier was
herkommt. Hier kommt gleich was. Big brain in your ass place. I get fucked in the ass
over here. Oh nee. Ich habe so gut Killchamp gemacht, aber nein. Können wir die noch diffusen?
Macht mal einer die Fuse-Champ. Alles muss man selbst machen. Nice, geht doch. Okay,
wir müssen gucken, dass von der Seite nichts kommt. Da sind sie nämlich schon. Okay,
stell es, stell es, stell es, stell es, stell es. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
lass mich in Ruhe. Suppression, habt ihr das gesehen? Oh. Suppression. Ah, fuck down.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das Suppression heißt. Wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich
nicht. So, komm, das können wir doch irgendwie defenden. Dann haben wir offiziell die Runde
gewonnen. Per Wubblos-Definition. Fuck, beinahe, beinahe, aber die machen ganz schön krass
Pusherino da rein. Okay, wir müssen rechts, wir müssen rechts defenden. Unbedingt rechts
ganz schön. Äh, links beinahe, nicht links beinahe. Komm mal her. Warte, wo ist, wo ist
er? Ah, Mist, ich dachte, es geht irgendwie. So, so, so, jetzt. Konzentrationschamp. Rättschamp.
Was das auf einmal macht, Champ. So. Easy win, zeige ich euch, easy win. Oder auch nicht.
Okay, äh, Munition, Munition, Munition. Gibt's nicht? Keine, keine, okay, lass mich,
lass mich einfach sterben, ist gut. Ich brauche, ich brauche Muni. Also, nicht Rätsen. Okay,
ich hab drei richtig gute Verzirrungen. Was hältst du von Call of Duty Cold War? Äh,
ich hab's gekauft, aber ich hab's nicht gespielt und ich hab auf den Multiplayer auch überhaupt
keinen Bock, ehrlich gesagt. Der Multiplayer von Modern Warfare war so Camp, nerviges rum
Campchampen. Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Okay, streck deinen Kopf raus, Alter. Du willst
mich jetzt nicht hierdurch beschießen, oder? Da war noch einer. Der, der Dude ist immer
noch da. Guckt euch an. Der ist immer noch da. Fuck, NA aimed, NA aimed. Nein, und jetzt
nicht aufgepasst. Und wir haben krass viele Tickets, er. NA aimed und dann nicht aufgepasst.
Beste. Nice, Dankeschön. Wo sind sie? Mal sterben, please, jetzt. Ist da noch was?
Ist nix mehr, okay. Da war noch was. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Aber wir müssen squad,
wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Manpower hier an dem Objective. Also, an sich ist es egal,
ob ich da mal zwischendurch sterbe oder nicht. Es juckt nicht, egal. Wir brauchen, wir brauchen
so viele Leute, wie es geht an dem Objective. Ob, ich kann nicht mehr richtig reden, ne.
Money, Money. Wisst ihr was, haha. Keck, weh. Ah, nee, moin, das ist ein, das ist ein.
Ah, yes. Nein, oh, der Trick hat nicht geklappt. Sein Ding aufheben, Munition legen und ihn
wieder retten alle. Das, das war jetzt zu, too, too smart wär das gewesen. Way too smart.
Da kommt gleich was. Da vorne sitzt noch einer. Irgendwo da, irgendwo hier in der Ecke und
ich sehe nicht, wo. Irgendwo da. Nein. Lege Händen, Champ.
Jetzt aber. Nice. Eine nicer Diffuse. Nein, nein, nein. Wo, wo, wo kommt denn das her?
Hier, da sind wir wieder. Da sind wir wieder. Da unten sind, geh schnell. Da ist noch einer,
da ist noch einer. Ja, M16, immer die M16, ja. Sonst kommen, sonst kommen sie nicht weiter
vor. Und irgendwo da unten ist noch einer. Okay, ist er down? Lebt er noch? Okay, da
ist down. Was mach ich denn hier eigentlich? Ich bin übelst, huge exposed. Das ist keine
gute Idee hier. Das ist eine ziemlich dumme Idee. Ja, sitzt und jetzt haben sie Lege Hände
gemacht. Fuck. Aber komm, jetzt bashen wir von der Seite rein. Bam, bababam. Jetzt will
er das wissen. Jetzt. Und jetzt. Und jetzt. Und jetzt. Und jetzt. Und jetzt. Nein. Das
war so close. Das war so close, Alter. Erstmal das halbe Team gekillt und dann auch fast
diffuse Hände gemacht. Es war fast durch, da hätten wir sie gehabt. Im Chat hat irgendjemand
gefragt, ob ich das bin. Ja, lustig. Oh, wie close war das gerade. Close Champ. Wir machen
jetzt Yolo Stels. Nein. Nein. Mist, hängengeblieben an dem Kackstein. Warum 48 FPS? Weil 48 FPS
relativ flüssig erscheint und weniger Bitrate braucht als 60. Dementsprechend 48 ist flüssig
und quasi weniger Artefakt. Das finde ich eigentlich das Beste zum Streamen. Und außerdem
ist es die cineastische Experience, die es da nur hier geboten gibt. Es ist ja auch so,
dass das menschliche Auge nur 24 FPS sieht und weil du zwei Augen hast, kommst du halt
genau auf 48. Und deswegen ist das die optimale Streaming-FPS. So sieht's aus. Ja klar, rennen
ins Fadenkreuz rein. Jetzt pushen sie aber gut rein. Jetzt pushen sie aber gut rein.
So, aber die Runde, die flutscht auch wieder ganz gut. Komm, wie sie immer so links-rechts
stelzen alle. Nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben. Exzellent. Nein. Moment, man
kann da aufs Dach. Das war mir neu. Fuck, ich wollte den jetzt wegsprayen. Hat nicht
funktioniert. Beiner, beiner, beiner. Weiß doch jeder. Ja, so ist es doch. Ist allgemein
bekannt. Manche sehen auch nur 12 FPS. Das sind dann die Leute, die sagen, ich sehe keinen
Unterschied zwischen 30 und 120. Die sehen nur 12. Hallo, Bring. Das ist Doppelscinematic.
Ja, das hab ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht. Stimmt. Inverse Cinematic. Sag mal, was ist
denn hier los? Kann das sein, dass hier in der Ecke gerade gefühlt 20 Gegner stehen?
Ja, klar. Waren da sich 12,5 pro Auge? Das kommt immer drauf an. Das kommt immer drauf
an. Bei manchen ist es 12, bei manchen ist es 24, bei manchen sind es auch 12,5. Aber
wir wissen ja, dass alle Leute unterschiedlich sind und da kann das schon mal sein. Ich meine,
es ist nicht umsonst so, dass manche Leute quasi zum Pro-Gamer geboren sind und manche
nicht. Das sind quasi die 48 FPSler und die sind halt quasi wie gemacht dafür. Was ist
denn hier oben eigentlich gerade los? Alter, was ist denn hier los? Eine Güte. Trau mich
hier nicht runter. Trau mich. Oh, der macht Legehenne. Fuck. Ich laufe genau in dem Moment
los, wo drei Gegner kommen. Der macht Legehenne. Ich wollte ihn eigentlich von der Seite catchen,
aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Genau da kamen drei Gegner. Das Stativ, Stativ, Stativ-Evel.
Was ist hier eigentlich gerade los? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir sind, ehrlich gesagt.
Wo sind, wo sind wir eigentlich nochmal? Ah, auf der Rolltreppe. Auf der Stelzer Treppe,
ok. Das heißt, die müssen wir, ok, ich muss mal gucken, dass die nicht zu sehr von der
Seite pushen. Ich kann da nicht runter. Unmöglich, unmöglich. Unmöglich, sagt's und stirbt er.
Haben die sich selbst eingenebelt oder haben wir die eingenebelt? Ne, ne, die nebeln uns
ein. Kommst du raus? Kommst du raus dahin? Wo, what? Wo kam denn der Dude her? Macht
ihn mal platt. Ok, jetzt müssen wir mal kurz. Ah nice, nice, nice, nice. Exquisite, exquisite.
Ok, damit rechnen die nicht. What? What, die Granate war doch recht oben. Na, ok, ok,
ok. Die wollen's wissen. Die Gegner sind, die sind, äh, pain's champ. Die sind hartnäckig,
die sind wirklich hartnäckig. Ne, ne, hier spawn ich lieber nicht. Hier auch nicht, ne.
Oh ne, rein hier, rein hier, rein hier. Jetzt champ. Ok, wir machen jetzt den easy mode.
Easy mode Sache. Ich camp, ich camp am M-Com. M-Com campen. M-Com campen, easy. Kann aber,
ich kann das nicht. Ich krieg da Anfälle, wenn ich lang am M-Com campen muss. Ok, jetzt
mal big brain flanks. Massive flanks. Guckt's euch an, guckt's euch an. Fuck, warum? Was
machst du hier? Du hast hier überhaupt nichts zu suchen, gehst du weg? Du hast hier überhaupt
nichts zu suchen. Und geschweige da nicht von hinten mich in die Ass zu bashen. Gegner
innen muss ich sagen, ja. Ist klar. Oh, der lebt ja noch. Big brain flank, das war big
brain flank. Das hätte fast funktioniert. Was hast du für eine CPU? Äh, ein 8700k,
bisschen übertaktet und eine 1080ti. Metro-Runden sind an. Guckt euch das mal an. 5815, ey. Low
brain, Nate, low brain, Nate. Ok, ich muss hier rüber, die pushen gleich, ich mach gleich
push a Reno. Ok, mach oder auch nicht. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich weiß nicht von wo der
dude kommt. Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, viel zu viele, viel zu viele, viel zu viele. Nate, zum Slowdown.
Jetzt ne Runde ab aimen hier. Die haben aber die bessere Posi, das ist das Problem. Fuck,
die haben die bessere Posi. Ah, scheiße. Das ist wirklich schwierig die da aufzuhalten.
Am besten ist in dem Tunnel, wo die uns auch gebashed haben vorhin. Ja, das Haus hier ist
auch top. Oh nein, Champaus, nein. Lege Henne am Start. Aber das M-Com geht noch, das M-Com
geht noch. Das andere, das andere M-Com ist das Schwierige. Da musste, da musste auf
Zack sein. Oh Mann, hier kommst du echt nicht vorwärts. Ok, jetzt alle auf das andere M-Com,
alle auf das andere M-Com. Das kann man, das kann man ganz gut defenden. Aber da muss man
auch wirklich sich drauf konzentrieren, nicht an jeder Ecke sterben, so wie wir das gerade
haben. Nein, nein, nein. Ok, der hat glaube ich, der hat gute Posi in der Mitte, das ist
richtig. Die machen es richtig, die smokeen uns ein. Ok, RIP. RIP Pepperonis. Ok, YOLO,
ah. Heißt es nicht M-Com? Was hab ich gesagt? Was hab ich gesagt? Im Eifer des Gefechts
bin ich da manchmal mit Wörtern, die sind dann nicht immer so akkurat, was ich dann
von mir gebe. Smokechampagne. Ich hab übrigens immer noch nicht gecheckt, wie man Smokes
ausrüstet. Ich hab das voll verdrängt. Muss man Smokes anlocken irgendwie? Muss man Smokes
anlocken mit mache 10 Granaten Kills oder so? Ich glaube ich mach auch zu viel Pushchamp
gerade. Von der Seite, von der Seite. Im M320 Slot, ja da hab ich nur Granaten oder? Oder
ist das automatisch Smoke? Es heißt die M-Coms, oh jetzt sind wir aber, jetzt sind wir aber
ganz korrekt, dass es nicht das M-Com oder die M-Com ist, die M-Coms sind. Man braucht
den Unterlauflauncher. War das so? Oh nein, ich kann mich da überhaupt noch mal dran
entfallen. Jetzt kriegen wir aber echt auf der Ass. Jetzt kriegen wir gerade richtig
auf der Ass hier. Massive. Ok viele können da nicht mehr sein, viele können da nicht
sein. F*** ich hab's versucht Leute, ich hab's versucht. Die heißen die App-Core. Ok ich
muss gleich mal nachgucken wie man das anlockt. Ich bin da zu Low-Brain für. Wir haben eh
gelost. Ok wie ging das nochmal? Aber die Stats können sich doch echt lehnen, 60 21,
ja komm. 60 21 geht. Ok Leute, ich sag euch, wenn jetzt wieder Bazaar kommt, oder ihr dürft
euch überlegen Chat, wollen wir noch eine Runde Bazaar spielen, falls jetzt Bazaar kommt
oder ein anderer Server? Weil... Waren da mal Leute in Game? Ich weiß nicht, hab ich
den Fatal am Start im Origin-Launcher? Dann... So, also wie ging das hier nochmal? Unlockable,
ok, was muss man unlocken? Unlock? Oh, ich muss 20 Kills machen, das hab ich nicht.
Ich hab keine 20 Kills mit 320. Hast du nicht meinen eigenen Server? Doch, doch. Anderer
Server? Anderer Server, ok. Ok, nochmal Bazaar geben wir uns nicht. Ok, also Fatal, wäre
nice, wenn du noch eine Runde mitspielst. Aber wenn es dir reicht, kann ich auch verstehen.
Wie schreibt man nochmal ein Team? K? Ok, zack. So, ähm, wo gehen wir mal hin? Wie lang
sind wir schon am Start? Auch schon über 2 Stunden kommt mir gar nicht so lang vor.
Ok, wenn es bock macht, macht es bock. For players, zu viel, zu viel, wir brauchen einen.
Rush, ok, die, sag mal, haben die Map Rotation? Haben die nur Map Rotation? Die haben nur
Bazaar und Metro, das sackt. Ok, was haben wir sonst noch? Toasty Metro, ne, das ist
auch nix. Official, ernsthaft? Wir haben Official, wir haben Official Server, die belegt sind.
What the hell? Das hab ich ja die letzten 150 Jahre nicht mal gesehen in dem Spiel. Official
Server in der, oha, geil. Holy Rush. Ok, joinen wir den mal. Gucken, mal gucken, ob da die
Big Brain Champs drauf sind. Queue Nummer 4. Sterbe, was ist das? 187, wenn ich das schon
lese, wieso, was ist mit 187? Ist das wieder irgendeine verkapte Nazi Zahl oder was, die,
wo ich das nicht kenne? Oh, hier, Cocomodate Server. Aber gut, wir sind ja fast drinne hier.
1-1 noch. Oh, Demavent Peak, Demavent Peak, excellent Server. Ist ja auch wirklich Official,
ja, die 4-player Server, die waren eigentlich immer die Officials, also unter anderem, aber
ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht erlaubt, Official in den Server-Titel
zu schreiben, ohne dass es Official ist. Oh, yes. Was ist das? Stand da nicht eben noch
eins. Ah, jetzt kann ich joinen, ok. Battlefield Logik. Alles klar.
aah, Chat, ich hab keine Ahnung, vor was ich spreche. So. Hallo? Ah, Demavent Peak, exquisite. Du wärst drauf, nice. Ja, auch Premium, klar, immer Premium. Ne, 64
mal in Rush ist Cancer. Ok, wo ist er denn, xfatal? Ah, du bist im Attackerteam. Äh,
kann man switchen? Teams, Teams, Switchteams? Ha, bam, da bin ich wieder. Auf geht's. Let's
go. Oh, das sind ganz gute Gehschnets hier am Start, so wie es aussieht. Da müssen wir
Big Brain Plays machen, Big Brain Plays. Guck hier, da siehst du schon mal, dass das gute
Leute sind, die wissen, wie man hier die Trickrouten macht. Ja. Trick 17 Route. Trickshot.
Äh, hallo? Oh nein, Pogger, Snaid. Alter, jetzt sofort. Was ist da oben, ist da oben
eh ne Drohne oder so? Drohnenstellz? Ok, ok, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Der denkt, dass ich jetzt hier rumlaufe. Der denkt, dass ich hier rumlaufe, aber. Oh,
ja, na klar. Ok, es war eine AEK, das ist ok. Ich wollte übelste Trickroute machen, ja.
Hier drüber, hier wollte ich drüber laufen, aber das ist Hochkantding. Was ist denn das
für, was ist da hier? Da geht aber nix grad. Äh, es sieht ein bisschen unbalanced aus
grad. Leute, ihr wisst ja, es ist immer unbalanced, wenn man verliert. Sag mal, habe ich da grad
einen Gegner gesehen? Direkt hier vor uns? Ha, lull, keck weh, keck, keck quadruple you
are. Hey, here's your medkit. Was? Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,
na. Ok, das ist wirklich unbalanced a shit. Team boy, Poggers. Cete, unbalanced. Oh nice
posey, nice posey, nice posey. Zeeelgut. Zeeelgut, posey Poggers, Poggers, posey Poggers,
Pockers, Pockers
Ha, wie er flairt, lull, haha, habt das gesehen
Wie er flairt, geht nix, da kann ich nicht hin, keine Chance, keine Chance, no chance
Haha, keck, dribble you, ich kann durch den smoke spotten, was meinst du denn, so nicht
So nicht, lull, kleinen nubbles, lull, lull, lull, lull, und jetzt, und jetzt, big brain plant, big nein
Ich wollte den plant des jahres machen, älter, den backstreet 360 Stealth plant
Ich hätte warten müssen, ich hätte warten müssen bis team respawn
Wow, hahaha, battlefield physics, wie spottet man ein Kuh
Oh, da kommt was, da kommt was, Leute
Ok, jetzt, jetzt, postchamp, postchampen, postchampen, nein, warum ist da immer einer
Nice, nice, nice, trx, trx, trx, postchamp, postchamp, postchamp
Toll das jetzt, nein, alter, was ein unlucky pech, unlucky hoch 10, äh, wirst du gerade
abgebashed noch auf dem weg, dass du dich selbst umbringst
Ok, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben
discernente, execution, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent
Inszen granade, inszen granade, ok, jetzt, jetzt, Polo guzz, ok, okay, Alter, lass mich
das hat sich nicht mal gelohnt dass sie gerätzt haben
oh wir haben geplanted poggers
anstrengend anstrengend alda postchamp postchamp postchamp kriegen wirs kriegen wirs ok ich muss
jetzt ran na was schreibt drei in den chat warum soll ich drei in den chat schreiben
ah war das voten was konnte man voten unlucky und da noch pech in kombination das
stellt euch das mal vor was kommt jetzt für eine map sam crossing oh nee metro nein nee
was hatten wir jetzt gerade was hatten wir gerade für eine map übels brain lag alda
wir haben dem aber ein peak gespielt ok was haben die für eine map rotation dem aber ein
peak kark island ist auch mal ganz nett als kark island kark island ist das kark die magische
übrigens net als defender mag ich die überhaupt net ok auto balance schlägt zu es lädt so lang
you got kicked from the server oh die fände come on bruh bruh alter bruh was hier los ok ich
zeige euch jetzt die besten die beste die beste kark island defender strats aller Zeiten also
passt auf erstmal weil es battlefield 3 ist immer springen beste kark island defender strats
aber wenn sie hier noch mal hoch
weiß gar nicht ob es hier hoch ging so beste best defender strats da kommt ein m track
da wollen wir nix den wollen wir in ruhe lassen und jetzt und jetzt ob servieren wir die die
kleinen stellze erst mal und jetzt kommt gleich irgendwelche im boot die man stellzen kann
alda was hier los so und gleich gleich steigen die ersten aus hoffe ich mal keck weh was haben
die schon immer vier lbs haben die vier lbs das stimmt doch nicht die haben doch keine vier lbs
normalerweise die haben doch keine vier lbs das ist doch nicht normal
haben die haben die vier lbs normalerweise wirklich
da oben da oben sitzt der schneiber man
leiber man lasse mich in ruhe
der schneiber man schießt mir in der ass
was macht man mal an die ump dran customize was habe ich denn habe ich da irgendwas sinnvolles
dran nee guck mal nix ich hab dafür nix nix anlockt
nee der ist nicht da wie hätte getroffen ich bin ich so der poggers pionier stellze
die sind schon wieder nah hätte ich doch hätte ich doch mal ich spiele wieder ich spiele
wieder sollt dieses das rumgestellte ich könnte auch ich mache jetzt die abfakt ich mache jetzt
die abfahrt klasse erst mal erst mal auto auto anti air rausholen igla x fatal bist du weg
ok nee squat warum bin ich noch in squad hat der hell bin ich da irgendwie raus oder so
ich bin verwirrt moment ich mache mal ein neues squad ich mache mal ein neues squad
alle bettel fied ein oder hier konnte man wie weit lief red squad ok ich bin in bravo
doch wisst ihr was ordentliche klasse wieder hier was denn hier los gerade man muss eine
positive kd haben um in einem squad zu sein quatsch das wäre das erste mal dass ich sowas
sehe jebaited you got jebaited wo sind wir denn hier gelandet aber sind wir hier gelandet
mein was weiß ich denn hier gerade los die runde sagt man ich hasse diese map als defender
so schlecht also macht keinen spaß die map ist nicht wirklich schlecht also im sinne
von schlecht also wenn man eine schlechte map spielen will er kann pika dilly spielen
oder sowas das eine schlechte map pika dilly man einer schlechtesten maps aller Zeiten
die ich je gesehen habe in je übergreifen über alle games pika dilly man spielst du
cyberpunk zu release ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich mal angucken ja meine maus ist weg wo ist
er wo ist der dude der helichamp der helichamp muss weg helichamp perpiss dich alter geiler
stelsa oh da oben ist einer i drill you a new asshole jawoll die sprüche der soldaten
sind einfach das beste einfach das beste in dem game und es ist aber der schütze
sagt aber auch schon ganz schön der schütze ist mal richtig schlecht guter schütze hätte
mich schon 30 mal gebasht hier unten guck dir an guck dir an lul ist er schlecht ist
er schlecht der helichamp mann lul schlecht ist der helichamp aller zeit
war was long range bettel hier hat mal sterben please
nein monial da da liegt da liegt moni ich glaube da liegt moni liegt da moni
nein munitionschamp liegt am munitionschamp nein das ist nur healchamp der helichamp drückt
das ist noch ein anderer der mich gekillt hat
supressed g18 übel so beest range
alter hier gucken ja drei spieler einen schneiber auf mich drauf
dass mich hier park zu spät ok da kommt was
der heli drückt nicht deswegen kriegen sie auch nichts gebacken weil der heli nicht drückt
der job vom heli ist hier uns in in die in die s zu ballern
hab ich gesagt pass auf jetzt lasse sich noch rausschießen der heli oder oder der springt
ab der springt ab über a oder so kann das sein dass man aus den heli gar nicht raus
geschossen werden kann ich glaube man kann aus diesen helis gar nicht rausgeschossen
werden ich will mir den stats guy angucken stats
sagen leute soll ich euch mal was sagen ich hab
schon lange nicht mehr so viel bock an battlefield wie heute
2 stunden wo man mal wieder sieht old but gold massive progression auf der 8 7 exzellent
hoffentlich jetzt gescheite map ach nee jetzt kommt ja kark island attacker
ok was hätten wir noch wohnen können bei dem server aber hier kark island dann kommt
nose hair kennels und dann gehts wieder von vorne los
oh nee bazaar sand crossing sand crossing würd ich mal gerne spielen
es seine crossing wie man früher immer gesagt hat
ja aus dem normalen attack heli kann man rausgeschossen werden ich bin mir aber nicht
sicher ob man aus dem ja doch aber gesniped kannst du zumindest
wenn ich weiß nicht ob du es mit assault rifle kannst ok
auf fährst du exzellent ich mach schieß action schießt
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so sicher ob das so was wie bullet drop hier hatte ich glaub
nicht oder hat es bullet drop äh nicht wirklich
oder zu das hat aber riesen spray
aber ich will eigentlich da rüber na
oh nee ich hab diese um pk klasse am start gehst du mal weg
damit kriegste doch nichts tot wieder ok nee nee nee nee nee nee
ich muss was anderes spielen ich muss m16 champs spielen
m16 champ alles bashen ok ist hier was
sind hier enemy stelzer oh jetzt achtung
in the ass bam so und jetzt mit einer ordentlichen waffe rein spawn
jetzt mit einer ordentlichen waffe rein spawn die erste die erste maps halt übelst cancer
hier nicht sterben nicht sterben nicht sterben über survive champ survive champ exzellent
so und jetzt gibt es noch einen sack
hat er gut funktioniert ok jetzt aber da unten sind ja noch mehr
sniper champs alter ok jetzt reicht es mir jetzt reicht
es mir jetzt wird gepusht champ easy ok ich muss vor ans m kommen
die stellsten das schon ich muss ans m kommen nicht diffusen kein diffusen nein kein diffusen
champ ok gut so kann man es auch mal
wo ist der dude hinter mir ernsthaft hinter mir wirklich
so jetzt hier da ist was nein nein lässt du mich in ruhe
lässt du mich in ruhe was geht mir den gegnern gerade ab
aus der behilfe du bist im stream du hast gesniped gibst zu stream geschniped hat er
hier ok ich gehe mal tank kann ich retten
exzellent
das ist so ein 24 7 chat typ ok jetzt aber
wow alter was ist ich bin schon wieder warum bin ich denn schon wieder mit dieser klasse
gespawnt ich will nicht mit dieser klasse spawnen
lass mich in ruhe ich will m416 spawnen nicht so ein crap
so pusht champ die gegner sind halt nicht dumm da haben wir
tolles爱 nawatta beach
lolo lolo lolo lolo lolo
da get ist cashier
so
wie
der get it in the ass hier. So. Jetzt aber. Jetzt. Jetzt. Stells champ. Okay ich camp
jetzt hier dass die leute bei mir spawnen können. Der kommt da unten gleich. Ist das
ein medic? Kann ich den retzen? Ah big brain action hier. Nee. Woah. Fuck. Aber nice play
oder? War doch ganz gut. Richtig jebaited. Richtig jebaited. Endlich. Nicht sterben.
Survive champ. Survive please. Survive champ. Jawoll. Survive champ. Oh da kommt noch einer.
Okay. Okay. Oh man. Jetzt. Jetzt gerade schießt der panzer hier hin. Jetzt wo ich stells action
mache. Aber wir kriegen glaube ich lege henne. Ich glaube wir kriegen lege henne. Die waren
fast am m kommt ran. Nice. Survive. Survive. Survive. Survive. Survive. Fuck. Ja der andere
macht den blatt. Jawoll. MVP. MVP. Der dude. Oh nee die defusen schon. Wo ist denn der
west? Alter wir haben gerade die mega krasse attack klar gemacht. Und alles andere ist
hinüber ey. Okay wisst ihr wir sind erstmal team playmen. Erstmal sagen team sackt deswegen
verlieren wir. Ich warte eigentlich ob man irgendwo spawnen kann aber dahinten fahren
wir bestimmt nicht los. Dahinten fahren wir nicht los. Okay das war's. Die haben die
richtig jopogas attack gerade gefahren da ohne. Der chat will mich bashen ey. Da ist
noch einer. Da ist noch einer. Lass mich in ruhe. Oh Gott fuck. Nice. Da kommt noch
einer. Okay wir brauchen Leute auf jeden fall ohne Leute geht hier grad nix. Fuck ich muss
clearen und wiederbeleben. Okay ich clear nicht. Bewege dich alter. Oh man ey hier geht
ja gar nix. Kannst vergessen hier kommst nicht vorbei. Du musst den chat nehmen und
alle bashen. Ja aber ich bin scheiß chatpilot ich kann das nicht. Und by the way wir haben
die map gewonnen. Weil wir sind weiter gekommen als die gegner. Also easy win. So siehts aus.
Dann guckt euch das mal an. Das war lächerlich. Ich wechsle gleich wieder auf jeden noob server
null. Da oben ist er. Guck mal da oben stehen 50 gegner. Okay Woutmap 1 Caspian Sand Crossing
Sand Crossing. Sand Crossing. Hat er das jetzt gecheckt? Slash 2 oder einfach nur 2? Okay
mal gucken was jetzt kommt. Hat er das noch gecheckt? Okay okay okay. Hoffentlich Sand
Crossing. Alter hoffentlich wird es child map. Zeig mal sieht man das hier? Map rotation
wir waren jetzt. Ah okay. Oh Caspian. Boah das wird ja immer ätzender. Ich bin chatpilot
genau. Kommt mal der andere 31. Das war der chatman. Das warst du in dem chat. Ja nice
also hier big brain chat aber ja. Da machst du nix dagegen. Ich hätte theoretisch die
ganze Zeit Stinger oder so geiern müssen aber das machst du auch nix gegen. So hoffentlich
Sand Crossing. Sand Crossing post champ. Sand Crossing please. Terran Highway. Terran Highway
ist auch gut. Terran Highway ist beste map. Übelst underrated a map. Aber find ich mega
nice. Die erste Base ist schwer als attacker. Danach gehts. Die erste Base ist ziemlich
schwierig. Wenn man nicht gegen total Kacknoobs spielt und wir spielen ja nicht gegen Kacknoobs.
Guck mal die Gegner an die sind eigentlich relativ okay champ. Okay wir probieren jetzt
mal was Leute. Wir probieren jetzt mal was. YOLO mode activated. YOLO mode activated.
YOLO mode activated. Okay und jetzt. YOLO mode activated. YOLO mode activated. YOLO
mode activated. YOLO mode activated. YOLO mode activated. Das war zwar nicht gewollt aber
okay okay champ. Alter die Basch in das Haus ey. Aber hier big brain play. Erst mal halbes
Team gebashed. Okay wir kommen nicht vorwärts. Okay lose champ lose champ. Das ist auch hart
gegengeschaltet die Gegner. Nope. Damals nix. Kann das sein das die Gegner haben standardmäßig
zwei Panzer das passt. Okay da brauchen wir small champ. Das ist kacke da kommste unkoordiniert
nicht durch. Keine Chance ey. Keine Chance. Terran Highway ist so ne geile Map aber das
erste ist wirklich schwer. Ja ist ja gut Panzer. Trepp dich Panz man. Wie geil ist
das Game ist mega poggers. Aber die Base ist also gegen halbwegs kompetente Gegner oder
sind halbwegs kompetente Gegner ist das unkoordiniert wirklich schwierig. Dann haben wir den Sniper
hier am Start. Geile Sniper Dude. Äh ich wechsle gleich wieder Server. Ich wechsle auf
Panzer. Ja Panz man ist klar. Wo ist der Panzer Typ?
Ähm. Was sind die Panzer destroyen? Destroyen ja.
Wir treffen uns doch nicht mal. Alter ist das Sack. Da ist eh da ist was davor. Da ist
das Kacke Haus davor. Das wird nix. Bin ja bekanntermaßen OP Panz man ey.
Bäm. Alter lass mich in Ruhe.
lake.
Alter fuck, ach der andere Panzer ist down, ah shit, da machst du nix, da geht auch nix
vorwärts, ich muss mir nen Hoopserver suchen, ich muss Hoops bashen, das macht's kein bock, bam
Alter guck mal wie viele das sind hier, guck mal vielleicht können wir hier spawnen noch
lul
Mist, ich dachte das ist Fleisch nennen
Nee kacke, ok Server wechsel, Server wechsel, so machen wir schon mal Poggas, Poggas, Poggas
Noobserver, so was haben wir denn hier zu bieten, oh guck mal wie voll, guck mal wie
viele, guck mal wie viele, nice, no explosives, die haben bestimmt auch wieder kacke, nur
Metro meine Fresse, Metro 247, Official 64 Mann Server, ok da sind bestimmt Kacke Noobs
drauf, ich will join erstmal auf 24 Mann Server, gucken was da los ist, was haben wir sonst
noch zu bieten, Official 64, 64, nur 64 Mann, das ist aber Müll, also wir haben zur Auswahl
nen Server mit gescheiten Gegnern, ähm und Metro Bazaar Dinger, ja das ist natürlich
schwierig, schwierig, so jetzt kommt die andere Seite, jetzt kommt ne Defender Runde, wieder
Attacker, da war noch ein Gegner eben hinter uns oder, jawoll, Kacke Noobs, lass uns nicht
bashen, so ist gut, so ist gut, was ist mit den Dudes los, bist du kaum gescheiter Kacke
Noob Gegner, wird gebashed, so muss es sein, so muss es sein, oh ich hab irgendeine Haie
im Mund, äh, kacke, oh, ok, easy win, easy win, guck, get joined, in progress 4-0 und
fast vorne, Leaderboard, so muss es sein, äh, Fatal ich weiß nicht ob du noch mitgekommen
bist auf den Server, keine Ahnung, ähm, als ja, mal gucken dass wir ins Team kommen, komm
wir sind mal nett, ich wollte gerade sagen, wir sind voll nett und retten den, oh ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, wir wollen hier hin, wir wollen hier hin, wir wollen hier hin, wir wollen
da auch von oben reinstelzen, ah, lässt mich in Ruhe, ok, wir machen jetzt, wir machen
jetzt, aggressive champ, ah der lebt nicht mehr, auf, Mist, ich brauch sein kit, ich
brauch dein kit, alter, nice, THX, what the hell, habt ihr das gerade gesehen, ist einfach
Golf, alles klar, ich eile, ich eile, Squad, Golf, join, excellent, was ist denn das, der
Server hat ja kaum Tickets, der Server hat ja kaum Tickets, guck mal hier, 46, ist ja
fast vorbei, du viel zu wenig Tickets für den 64 Mann Server, da machst du einen push
und es ist weg, das geht ja nett, das geht ja nett, Anzeige ist raus, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ooo, LIKES, nice.
kann man hier durchballern? nice! oh shit, wusste gar nicht, dass man da durchschießen kann
ok, yolo mode, yolo mode activated, yolo mode activated, ja, nein
jetzt haben wir probieren können, wow, wow, poggers, poggerino
da ist was los, ok, das hat zu wenig tickets, der hat wirklich, also legit, viel zu wenig tickets
na, na, postchamp, postchamp, kriegen wirs noch? easy, ich habe nichts gesagt, ticketanzahl genau
richtig, nee, mal ernsthaft, 75 tickets, guck mal, wir sind ja schon jetzt wieder 5 tickets down,
bevor wir überhaupt aus der base ge-moved sind, guckt euch mal an, 13 tickets down oder 10 tickets
down fast, obwohl wir nicht mal aus der base ge-moved sind, das ist halt echt dumm, das ist
richtig dumm, der server hat zu wenig tickets, ich mein, wegen der 64 mann und da ist auch noch
ein pence man am start, der server mit ein paar tickets mehr wäre richtig poggers, ok,
die panzer ist weg, ihr müsst halt retzen ohne ende, ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ok, hallo, ok ich bevorzuge es ja eigentlich
rechts runter zu gehen jetzt
Guck mal wir sind schon wie viele tickets wir down sind, bevor wir hier raus gekommen sind, ist doch der witz
Okay, YOLO mode activated, erstmal. Nein, nein. Sag mal, steht da einer unter uns, kann das sein?
Ach da steht einer
Und keiner sieht ihn und ich habe ihn auch nicht gesehen
Oh, TRX. Ich glaube der Typ lebt noch
Okay
Okay, wir müssen wir müssen weg hier ohne scheiß, wir müssen mal sowas von weg aber das ist gut
Die sind mit ihrem Panzer weg, die sind mit ihrem Panzer weg, das ist für uns extrem pock
Alter Battlefield
Ich lieg da, ich lieg da schlecht
Wow, Alter wie ist rubber banded
Wir müssen mit die andere Ecke
Achtung, nade
Nee, nee, nee, die tickets sind zu wenig Leute, die tickets sind viel zu wenig, guckt euch das mal an
Kek weh, der Server war perfekt, die lassen sich so gut weglatschen
Die lassen sich so bashen, Alter
Alter, das Battlefield-Movement ist gerade gegen uns
So, wir gehen mal aufs Dach
Machen Dachstells
Hallo
Was ist denn das da?
Irgendwas, was nicht kaputt geht
Das war so eine Respawn-Station
Guckt euch mal an, wir sind so gut durchgepusht und die Tickets sind alle
Alter, die config suckt ja mal hardcore
Ich mein besser, können wir bei 64 man ja gar nicht durchpushen
Ich mein, was ist das?
Oh, da war noch ein rechts, war noch einer, fuck
Ja, aber das ist, ich mein 75 Tickets für 64 man, da kann jeder, das war übertrieben gesagt, da kann jeder einmal sterben
Pro Mcom, hallo
Nee, nee, nee, das ist Müll
Aber ne Runde machen wir noch
22-4, so muss das sein
Zumal es für Attacker sogar noch viel besser ist, weil die haben halt keine Tickets, ne
Attacker können sich im Endeffekt einfach nur in die Gegner werfen und traden und gewinnen
Nee, das ist dumm
Das riecht stumm
Übrigens schön, dass so viele dabei sind
War ne Frage an den Chat, seid ihr normalerweise auch öfters mal hier?
Und seid ihr jetzt am Start, weil Battlefield 3 ist oder seid ihr irgendwie über Twitch hier drauf?
Habt ihr jetzt irgendwie über Twitch gefunden?
Das wird mich mal interessieren
Weil normalerweise mach ich ja gar keine Gaming-Geschichten und für Gaming sind relativ viele Sachen da
Oder wenig Gaming-Geschichten, gar keine würd ich nicht sagen, ab und zu war schon
Also die Tickets sind wirklich zu wenig
Was haben wir denn hier für ne gescheite Waffe, komm mal her
War die gut? Kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern
Ach die war das, die hat zu wenig Schuss gehabt
War noch nie hier
Durch Follow, okay
Okay manche, manche sind auch neu, interessant, interessant
Oh, oh, ich muss da hinten rum
Ja, ja, ja
Hier kommt noch irgendwo ein Tank gerade, oder?
Sind hier immer noch ein Tank am Start?
Ah ne, das ist unserer
Ich repär dich, nein
Oh, depends man
Get rekt Panzer
Ist da noch ein Panzer?
Oder lebt noch?
Der Dude hier, da hat noch einer gelebt gerade
Was, was? Wie haben die denn das Objective bekommen gerade?
Keck
Oh, das war ein Hit, hätt ich nicht gedacht
Okay, die müssen jetzt erstmal bashen da drüben
Oh hier ist aber voll
Erstmal eine Mate
Und jetzt hier, easy durchs Fenster
Oh, oh
Ah, Schweißchamp, Schweißchamp
Weggeschweißt
Weggeschweißt, Schweißchamp, jawoll
Ich hab mehr Ammo, Respekt
MonkaS
Oh, jetzt hast du meine schöne
Meine schöne Sache kaputt gemacht
Alter, was ist das hier für eine Fahrerei?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ah
Guck mal Leute, ohne Mist, viel zu wenig Tickets
Das war eine Attack
Und Runde vorbei
Nee, das ist doch
Oh, oh, oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Schweißchamp
Guck mal
Ich mein, es war per – Fuck, ich guck das an
Ich hab 5-0
Die Runde war permanent Action
Und ich hab auch ganz gut gebashing
Und es ist vorbei
5-0
Nee, nee, nee
Weißt du, was die hätten mal machen können?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, die hätten alle Waffen-Unlocks machen können für...
Die hätten jemand, der Twitch Prime kriegt, die hätten sie noch die Waffen-Unlocks geben können.
Weil es hat doch keiner Bock, waffenfrei zu spielen in einem 10 Jahre alten Game.
Hat doch keiner Bock drauf.
Macht doch auch keiner.
Oh, mag ich auch nicht so.
Mag ich auch nicht so.
Passt unmöglich. Ja, die Map ist nicht balanced als Attacker.
Ich sag's euch mal, wie es ist.
Die hätten Battlefield 3 als Service-Game machen müssen.
Ich hätte ja nicht gedacht, dass ich das mal sage, dass ich sowas haben will.
Battlefield 3 oder vielleicht auch Battlefield 4, aber ich wäre eher...
Die hätten Battlefield 3 als Service-Game machen sollten für 5 Jahre.
Und hätten das quasi dann in die Richtung von Battlefield 4 weiter.
Entwickeln müssen.
Nee.
Ich lass mich sheep-champen.
Ich bin halt Sturmsoldat, das sackt halt ein bisschen als dafür, ne?
Aber ich will eigentlich nur mitgenommen werden irgendwie Richtung Gegner.
Guck mal oben, Koggers am Himmel.
Koggers-Kreisels.
Aufspringt raus.
Au.
Okay.
Oh!
Mit dem RPG, mit so einem Querschläger-RPG.
Was soll denn das? So richtig schön am Bashing gewesen sein.
What the fuck?
Wir wollen nicht sterben.
Au, au, au, au, von wo?
Bestimmt irgendwie so ein Dude da oben auf dem Sniper-Turm.
Nee, da links ist irgendwo so ein Sniper-Spast am Start.
Ah, ich glaub ich war zu spät.
Und ich war ohne Mist, die Attack läuft gut.
Hey.
Lass mich rein.
Oh, da stehen sie neben mir.
Pains-Champ, Z-Pudding, ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht alles vorlesen. Dankeschön.
Wer hat alles was gekriegt hier?
Jain, Midnight-Wolf, Jerem, Maurice, Captain Caruso, Z-Pudding, Dankeschön.
Nice Poggers-Subscriptions hier.
Poggers.
Objective has been neutralized.
Gehst du weg? Wo kommt er? Wo kommt er?
Lul.
Au.
Ich seh nix.
Ah, fuck, fuck, fuck, das hätte so geil... Guck mal hier, die waren alle aufgereiht vor mir.
Bam, ba, ba, bam.
Fadl ist immer noch drin, Poggers-Position, Alter.
Kurz, kurz Ragen, kurz Ragen, Rack-Champ.
I get fucked in the ass here.
Hallo?
Ah, ah, ah.
Ha, ha. Ich hol dich, ich hol dich, hopp.
Bester Shoot ever, ja, so sieht es aus.
Vielleicht besser, aber auf jeden Fall Multiplayer-mäßig ganz weit vorne.
Was hältst du von Battlefield 5? Nix, ist nicht mein Fall.
Ich sag nicht, dass es schlecht ist, aber...
Ich warte, bis da einer rausspringt, dann wird er gebashed.
Mist.
Zu viel gesprayt.
Rechts ist einer.
Abkürzung ist Champ.
Und jetzt rettet's Champ.
Ah, das sind Plays hier, Leute, so muss man was machen.
Oh, oh, oh, Penz-Man.
Da vor uns war es, ich seh nix.
Wir müssen, eigentlich müssen wir noch ein Stückchen weiter.
Da ist was.
Oben ist was drauf gewesen.
Wir holen, wir holen, wir holen, der kommt gleich her.
Alter, die werden gebashed. Das ist ja fast wie an Weihnachten.
Ja, ist denn schon Weihnachten. Ist denn schon Weihnachten, Leute.
Ja, ist schon Weihnachten.
Ja, ist schon Weihnachten, guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt's euch an.
Ah, fuck, okay, jetzt war ich ein bisschen, jetzt war ich ein bisschen übermütig, ey.
Jetzt war ich ein bisschen übermütig.
Zu cready hier, in fünf Gegner reingerusht.
Fatal macht das, Fatal macht easy, easy objective play hier, ich seh's schon.
Ich komm rüber zum M, zum M-Com.
Entschuldigt, nice.
Oh, okay, gehen wir mal weiter.
Bashen, alter, bashen.
Ah, easy, die Runde gewinnen wir easy.
Das ist ja fast wie 2005, weiß gar nicht, wann kam das Game raus?
Das ist ja fast wie 2012, was kommt als nächstes, als nächstes zeigt sich Sylvana hinten, oder was?
Das ist ja wie 2013, ne, wann kam das raus?
Ich weiß nicht, Leute, ich bin grad zu verwirrt.
Monka ist der Panzer, der Panzerman.
Könnt ihr mich in Ruhe lassen, please?
Leute, sorry, ich kann nicht retten, hier ist grad ein bisschen viel los.
Jetzt, bam, zack.
Und jetzt hier raus.
Jetzt, man.
Oh, nein, lass mich in Ruhe, lass mich in Ruhe.
Lass mich, lass mich, lass mich, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ist da hinter uns einer gelandet grad?
Nein, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Gegenüber ist einer.
Ich seh' ihn nicht.
Battlefield 2 kam 2005, ja, ich kann mich da jetzt grad nicht drauf konzentrieren, chat.
Da ist noch irgendwas.
Da war's, da war's, ich hab ihn gesehen.
Aber der ist wahrscheinlich gleich down.
Oh, was hier, was ist hier?
Warte, warte, warte, warte, wo war er hier?
Ich glaub' jetzt alles, war der hier noch im Haus?
Nee, nee, okay, okay, alles klar, alles klar, alles klar.
Guck mal, hier 34.
Kack triple U, äh, quadruple Penta U ist das.
Kack Penta U.
Manchmal ist schon ziemlich in Stumsel, was ich erzähle, oder?
Ja, meine Güte, sterb mal.
Da oben ist er.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Hallo, Battlefield.
Jumpen, please.
Äh, ich rätst dich, ich rätst dich.
Müssen wir hier noch gucken, dass wir die kriegen.
Zack, jawoll.
Fehlen nur noch Dual mit dem Frisur.
Hey, ich wollt' am Wochenende mit ihm was aufnehmen, aber irgendwie will er nicht.
Irgendwie will er nicht.
Ich weiß, er sagt ja nicht, dass er nicht will, aber...
Ich glaube, er will nicht.
Er will eben nicht so festlegen auf YouTube-Zeug.
Oh, wenn ich jetzt noch, wenn ich jetzt noch ne Muni...
Moin, liegt da hinten ne Muni-Kiste?
Nee, das ist ein Muni-Dude.
Muni, please.
Muni, Muni, Muni, Muni.
Ah, jawoll.
Du bist der Beste.
Ja, bester, bester Mann.
Gameplay fürs nächste Video.
Äh, ich nehm's nicht auf.
Ich hab auch kein Shadowplay an, aber ich kann's mir aus dem Stream...
Aus dem Stream rausschnibbeln.
Das wär jetzt hier fast der nächste hier Warzone-Huskers-Kill gewesen, den Typ am Fallschirm.
Ich guck mehr Warzone-Streams als selbst Warzone zu spielen.
Die einzig wahre Warzone ist Battlefield.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gegner.
Lul.
Greift alle nix.
Hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich.
Da drinnen ist einer.
Okay.
Da war noch mehr.
Ah, nee.
Okay, wir machen Flank, Flank-Champ machen wir jetzt.
Big Brain Flank-Champ.
Massive Flank, Big Brain Flank kommt jetzt.
Erst mal aufs Dach.
Wir müssen erst mal aufs Dach.
Und vom Dach werden sie gebashed.
Dach, Dach-Stell-Spash.
Nein!
Die perfekte Pose und dann von irgendeinem Typ von der Seite weggeknallt.
Weg in der Ass gebashed, ey.
Nein!
Okay, 40 Kills.
Die 40 Kills machen wir voll.
40 Kills muss sein.
40 Kills Battlefield-Rush-Gameplay 2020.
Konker-S.
Okay, jetzt zu viel los.
Ich geh wieder aufs Dach.
Dach-Stell ist das Beste.
Da fliegt ein Chat los, okay.
Dach-Stell.
The Fast Mover.
Okay, ich muss jetzt schnell Kills machen.
Schnell, schnell Kills.
Okay, kommt raus hier, Leute.
Kommt her, kommt her, kommt her.
Ich muss euch killen.
Okay, next, next, next.
40 Kills, 40 Kills.
Keine Zeit für Mini-Packs.
Wo sind die?
Wo sind die Kills?
Nein!
Nein, wir haben keine 40 Kills bekommen.
Easy.
Instant, Instant.
Gameplay löschen jetzt.
37, 5 nur.
Versagt, Leute.
Aber trotzdem da ist das Gameplay.
Ich wollte unbedingt noch die 40 Kills haben.
Ich meine, 40 Kills in dieser Runde, da ist ja kaum was zu killen da.
Kann ich Shadowplay starten, irgendwie?
Nee.
Hol ich mir das aus dem Stream, hol ich mir das aus dem Stream, da ist halt ein bisschen
mit Chet dabei, oder?
Fast eine Nuke, ja.
Chet, fast eine Nuke.
Okay, was kommt jetzt?
Ach so, jetzt müssen wir nochmal die Fenden, stimmt ja.
Stimmt ja.
Auf geht's.
Auf geht's, auf geht's.
Zack.
Ein paar Mal Panzer.
Komm, wir probieren es mal.
Wir probieren mal, Panzman zu machen.
Ey, hallo?
E?
Please?
Was ist das?
Ich habe eine halbe Stunde E gedrückt.
Und jetzt bin ich wie meine kacke Engie-Klasse ohne Panzer am Start.
Jawoll.
So muss sein.
Aber immer noch besser, wie die Dinger nur im Spawn-Bildschirm spawnen zu lassen.
Achtung, Trickshot, Trickshot.
Äh, ja.
Nochmal, Trickshot.
Oh, excellent.
Ich sehe es schon.
Ich bin der Trickshotter vor dem...
Oh, Panzer.
Gegner Panzer klauen.
Panzer klauen.
Please, please.
Nein, nicht kaputt gehen, nicht kaputt.
Der Panzer ist kaputt.
Wie, das war nicht gehitted?
Okay.
Fuck.
Ich wollte unbedingt den Gegner Panzer klauen.
Gegner Panzer klauen ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Instant Lose.
Was machen die denn da hinten?
Elternsprechtag oder was?
Ah ne, ist Corona gerade, gibt's das ja nicht.
Ja, logisch.
Ah ja, habe ich vergessen, Chat.
Corona Selbsthilfegruppe war da hinten gerade.
Nein.
Lull.
By the way, seit wann hält ein Jeep, seit wann hält ein Jeep mehr als ein RPG aus?
Ist das neu?
Nein, das wird nicht, ist eine rhetorische Frage.
Natürlich wird das nicht neu sein.
Das Spiel ist halt nicht neu.
Jolo, Jolo, Jolo, Jolo Panzmann Attack machen wir jetzt.
Sag mal, der sieht nichts, der Typ, oder?
Ist der blind?
Den messern wir jetzt.
Ich will nicht messern.
Alter, du wirst jetzt gemessert.
Ha!
Bam!
Oh ne, gar kein Messer am Start gewesen.
Oh, noch ein Panzer.
Oh, oh, der RPG, der RPG.
Mal gucken, was er macht.
Okay, okay, flanken wollen sie mich.
Flanken, sie wollen mich flanken.
Nein!
Was sind das für Bälle?
Was sind das für Bots?
Prime Noobs!
Ja, was denn sonst?
Was sind Prime Noobs?
Oh, in the ass?
Was machen die hier?
Ey, die kriegen ja gar nichts mit.
Die sind absolut, komplett Prane, Low IQ, Low Prane, 3 Head, Extremes.
Achtung, Achtung!
Trickshot, Trickshot!
Trickshot!
Ah!
Nächster Trickshot!
Achtung, Trick!
Trick17-Shot!
Ah, ah, ah!
Pause!
Ah!
Close Champ war das.
Aber die Fallschirme auf A runter.
Too close Champ!
Oh, ah, yes!
Eine nice Bodentextur.
Die wollte ich schon immer mal sehen.
Also wer sie noch nicht kannte, die weltbekannte, was auch immer das sein soll, Berge von Caspian
Border, da sind sie.
Gegnerteam richtige PP-Gas, ja, aber sowas von Chat.
Ja, world first Caspian Border Bodentextur.
Noch never before irgendwo.
Easy clap, easy clap.
Nicht zu sagen, um nicht zu sagen.
Übrigens, falls ich irgendwo was vergessen habe an Subs vorzulesen, tut es mir leid für
mich, ich bin etwas konzentriert auf das Game.
Ja, gerade.
Ah, Rush!
Rush Firestorm!
So muss das sein.
Auch wieder nicht unbedingt meine favorite Map.
Ich glaube die ganzen Heli-Piloten feiern das übelst ab.
Rush Firestorm.
By the way, eventuell letzten zwei Runden, dann habe ich so viel Hunger, dass ich das
essen muss.
Deploy, wir sind Attacker.
Ich laufe, ich laufe.
Ne, ich laufe nicht.
Ich mach Jeepchamp.
Jeepchamp.
Das ist von Amazon an Battlefield 3 Pro.
Ey, du musst wirklich kein Battlefield 3 Pro sein, um hier was zu reißen.
Ich hab ewig nicht gespielt.
Ich hab noch ein bisschen.
Massive driving.
What the fuck?
Was ist das für ein Typ?
Ich muss hier raus.
Big Brain Driver.
Ich retz dich.
Ich bin gleich da.
Ja, nice.
Da war was.
Ich hab was gesehen auf der Map.
Rechtsseite.
Hopp.
Ist hier was in der Mitte?
Kann man hier ran?
Hol dich.
Nein, nein.
Da hinten ist noch was.
Ich weiß aber echt nicht, wo.
Wo ist der denn?
Ach da.
Lul.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Grenades.
A fast mover.
Ich glaube, wir sollten hier gar nicht so schnell liegen.
The fast mover.
Die Gegner sind so random, die kannst du gar nicht mal predikten, wo hier irgendwie was
passiert.
Nein.
Geh sofort.
Battlefield.
Ich hab die Gegner in der Map gesehen, der ist einfach verschwunden.
Paid actors, ja.
Der ist einfach verschwunden gerade.
Nice.
Sehr gut.
Woah.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, ey.
Jetzt haben sie Blut geleckt.
Jetzt haben sie Blut geleckt, die Gegner.
Jetzt haben sie gefunden, wie man in die Ironsides geht.
Jetzt haben sie gefunden, wie man ein Equipment ausequippt.
Oh.
Der macht Trickshots.
Guck mal, der macht, der macht iklar Trickshots.
Was ist mit dem los?
Nee, ich glaube, der weiß einfach nicht, wie man das Ding verwendet.
Der macht keine Trickshots.
Der ist Erbsenhirn.
Nein, jetzt ist auch noch der Panzer voll.
Was machen die denn da gerade alle?
Was ist das irgendwie?
Kindergeburtstag, was ist hier los gerade?
Guckt euch das an.
Was ist, was bin ich sehend, Alter?
Was ist hier los?
Was, nur noch 37 Tickets?
Ernsthaft?
Die Runde ging noch gar nicht los?
So, einfach mal, einfach mal hin gesprayt.
Die Runde ging noch gar nicht los.
Max, rasier mal.
Bis ich da vorne bin, ist die Runde vorbei.
Okay, Achtung, Massive Kills, Massive Kills hier.
Face Bewerbung ist raus.
Brauch kein Sniper, ich mach das mit dem Assault Rifle.
Suppression, in your face suppressed.
Massive Suppression, in your face suppressed.
Da stirbt gleich einer, wenn es so weitergeht.
Was?
Okay, das war lucky, das war extrem lucky, dass das funktioniert hat.
Okay, jetzt aber, fuck him up, machen wir, wir fucken
ihn ab.
Gehen wir mal, gehen wir mal durchs, durchs Häusi.
Hauschamp.
Hauschamp, ich seh nix.
Fuck.
Okay, wir machen Trick 17, wir warten, wir warten bis die Diffusen kommen.
Ich, der war, ich war markiert.
Ich wollte sagen, wir warten bis die Diffusen kommen und dann gehen wir ran.
Und killen den Diffuser und kriegen das noch so irgendwie, aber, das ist grad übelst
Cloud Fierce, dann weißt du überhaupt nicht, was läuft.
Sniper Dude da hinten, okay komm, 9 Tickets jetzt, jetzt, jetzt zählst, jetzt kommst
drauf an Leute, jetzt, jetzt oder nie, jetzt oder nie, lege Henne, nein, der Gegner hat
rumgewackelt.
Okay, das machen, komm, das haben wir, komm, das haben wir, komm, das haben wir, das haben
wir, das haben wir, das haben wir, Leute, das haben wir.
Hauschamp, Hauschamp, das haben wir.
Nice.
Wir haben's, wir haben's.
Was ist denn hier los?
Leute, ihr müsst nicht mehr zum M kommen, das M-Com ist weg.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch, ich blicke, ich blicke, ey, mein Brain ist überlastet gerade.
Danke schon für die ganzen Rätsel, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das verdient habe, aber,
was ist denn los?
Battlefield Spotting, Battlefield Spotting, Battlefield 3 Spotting, beste.
Moment
747 750 ist viel zu wenig okay, der pence man trifft nix
Als pence man auf auf auf auf auf auf wuff wuff wuff wuff wuff
Wuff ich mache jetzt jolo ich renne als jolo mit schreien
Nein ich habe mich gerade hingelegt und den moment habe ich wahrscheinlich richtig fetten headshot kassiert
Ich habe die kriegen sie eh nicht gebacken ich renne einfach rein aber das haben sie gebacken bekommen
Big brain place sind jetzt angesagt leute ab jetzt chat ab jetzt big brain place only
Ab jetzt ist ernst
Only
Zu
Hallo game
Okay, da konnte ich jetzt nichts für das war game hat mich gebadet
Game hat mich gebadet, das war, war Big Brain Play, eindeutig.
Wie wir haben das nicht mal bekommen?
Moin, Nealon, Waltz, warst du nicht vorher schon da?
Gebadet, so jetzt müssen wir legen, jetzt muss die Legehenne gemacht werden, jetzt muss die
Legehenne, oh geht die Original, Original Legehenne, Alter, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Zeigt euch mal, jetzt stehen die auch noch mit zwei Panzern und ballern rum.
Das ist ja, das ist keine High IQ Plays, aber die treffen wenigstens nichts.
Okay, die treffen nichts, wir verlassen uns einfach mal drauf, dass die nichts treffen,
die treffen nichts Leute, easy, easy, easy, easy, die treffen nichts, ich sag euch, die
treffen nichts.
Fuck, okay, es war Big Brain Play, allerdings hat die Ausführung noch ein bisschen gehapert.
Okay, wir haben noch einen Attack, ein Attack, das Erbsenhirn ist fast dran, das Erbsenhirn
rettet jetzt die Runde, ich sag's euch, nein noch ein Ticket, nooo, okay, ah, ah, ah,
ah, der Lumpenmech ist auch da, lose, nooo, guckt euch mal die Ranks von den Gegnern an,
guckt mal hier, null, das sind ja wirklich absolut Frischfleisch hier, ich hab gedacht,
die treffen nichts, oh, ich hab Hunger, ich hab übelst Hunger, spielen wir noch, komm
wir spielen noch die Defense Runde, die Defense Runde, Casper, ne, Firestorm spielen wir noch
mal, das Erbsenhirn, ja, ja, du hast, du hast es aber fast gerissen, ich hab's gesehen,
er hat ja schon 4 Stunden fast on, jetzt mal ernsthaft Chat, ne, wäre das nicht geil,
wenn es ein Spiel gäbe, was man wieder so suchen könnte wie Battlefield 3 und was ich
den ganzen Tag ohne nachzudenken einfach streamen könnte, aber geht ja nicht, weil sich EA
gedacht hat, nope, wir machen lieber scheiß Battlefield Spiele, nein, ich komm jetzt
nicht auf den Panzer, ok, du bist, Tankman, Tankman, nein, Alter, hab ich diese komische
Engineer Klasse am Start, ok, dann müssen wir gegnerische Panzmanns bashen, hatte man
als Engineer hier nicht C4, ah ne, ne, ne, Support war C4, und hier waren auch noch welche,
da waren auch Gegner, ja, Battlefield Physics, hier muss man sich ja streiten um Gegner, vorbei,
ok, Achtung, Big Brain, Big Brain Plays, Moment, Moment, Moment, Prediction, die Prediction
ist raus, Calculated, Calculating, Calculating, Calculating, oh, war das knapp, Leute, ich
sag's euch, das war Millimeter, wo das vorbeigeflogen ist, Calculation Failed, Float Error, Rundungsfehler,
wo stelltsen die eigentlich rum, ah, ich kann nicht Leute, ich hab nichts zum Rätselball,
geht ja gar nix grad, Captain Peng rettet die Runde, nice Captain Peng, easy, die Gegner
sind echt ultra low brain, ok, ich hab zu wenig Schuss um viel zu killen, ok, ok, ok,
nein, da kann man nicht durch, oh, da aim das, da aim das ab, ok, ich muss jetzt mal
in ne ordentliche Klasse spawnen, mit dem Ding kriegst du ja nix tot, alter, Scar, 21 Schuss
und dann macht so net mal Damage.
So, jetzt aber.
Siehst du?
Die Noobs! Die Noobs! Alter! Die Noobs! Die Noobs fliegen den Heli!
What the hell? Was war das denn grade?
Ich dachte eigentlich sind jetzt drei Gegner tot, aber nein.
So, so gütig die Hit Detection manchmal ist.
So sehr.
Kriegt man auch manchmal auf der Ass.
Ist hier noch was? Ist hier noch was? Pause.
What?
Das hat er überlebt! Glaubt ihr das?
Oh!
Der Noob-Basher, aber krass.
Richter Noob-Basher.
Noob-Basch-Soar.
Guck mal, erste Hälfte mit Kack-Klasse gespielt und dann M416.
Das sind richtige Weihnachtsnoobs, aber hardcore Weihnachtsnoobs.
Das war eine ganz, ganz merkwürdige Kack-Runde.
Ok, mal gucken was für eine Map als nächstes kommt.
Vielleicht machen wir die nächste Map noch.
Wenn mir die Map gefällt, spielen wir die noch.
Wenn mir die Map nicht gefällt.
Also Leute, eine Runde Pause-Champ jetzt.
Pause-Champ. Pause-Champen, dass was Gutes kommt.
Nur mit mindestens 20 Pause-Champs im Chat.
Nur kommt eine gute Map.
So, also.
Pause-Champ per Minute.
PPM.
So, mal gucken ob eine gute Map kommt.
75 Tickets ist lächerlich.
Ok, also.
Was kommt? Was kommt?
Sand-Crossing!
Jawoll, die spielen wir noch.
Die spielen wir noch.
Ich hoffe ihr habt alle Pause-Champed.
3 Pause-Champs sehe ich im Chat.
Ich habe hier 30 Sekunden.
4 Pause-Champs, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
Ok Chat, an euch lag es nicht, dass die Map gekommen ist.
Zu wenige Pause-Champs.
Übrigens, B ist die schwerste, schwerste M-Com im ganzen Game.
Da musst du direkt hin.
Und gleich Legehennen machen, gleich Legehennen.
Instant Legehennen.
Jawoll.
Instant Legehennen, jetzt hier hinten rein campen.
Das ist das Land.
Ich hole euch, ich hole euch.
Der Typ sitzt immer noch da oben im Haus.
Ich glaube es ist verloren.
Aber der Typ sitzt oben im Haus.
Hauptsache schön.
Der Typ sitzt oben im Haus.
Kann man das hier nicht aufmachen?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Alter, wir gehen jetzt hier durch.
Wir gehen hier durch wie nichts gerade.
Oh, mit dem letzten Schuss Leute.
Letzter Schuss.
Oh, da stand noch einer drin.
Fuck.
Da stand noch einer im Haus.
Da campt er.
Da sitzt der Schneibermann mit der PP2000.
Exzellenter Typ.
Exzellent.
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
Mit dem Exzell...
Oh nein.
Fuck.
Ich wollte da rein und dem Typ meine M416 in der Ass.
Der respawnt gleich.
Was ist denn hier?
Aua.
Ich hab mir voll auf die Hand geschlagen.
Jetzt kann ich die Hand finden.
Äh, bitte was?
Was hat mich denn da gerade...
...gestellst?
Okay.
Jetzt aber.
Jetzt kommt Exzellent Attack.
Big Brain Attack.
Only in Battlefield.
Wusste ich, dass da einer ist.
Oh, knapp, knapp, knapp, knapp.
War da nicht eben noch ein Dude?
Ich hab doch eben noch was gesehen.
Wo sind die kleinen Paws Champs?
Wer war da?
Alter, das ist zu viel.
Das ist mir zu.
Das ist mir zu viel gerade.
Ich mach den.
Nein!
Jetzt fangen die auch auf einmal was an zu treffen.
By the way, die Tickets sind immer noch viel zu wenig.
Dude, Dude, Dude.
Okay, YOLO Mode.
Jawoll!
Äh.
Man stirbt da doch gar nicht, wenn man runterhüpft.
Warum bin ich jetzt gestorben?
Ich mach's euch.
Exzellent Physik.
Exzellent.
Sehr, sehr exzellent.
Der Typ.
Was willst du da machen?
Ja, Riders, war's gut.
Wie gesagt, hier, das ist jetzt auch letzte Runde.
Ich hab brutalst Hunger.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die Gegner überhaupt sind gerade.
Ich blick ihnen mal durch.
Ach, jetzt kommen wir mit dem LLV hier lang.
Aber guck mal, wir sind schon Tickets down, bevor die Base offen ist.
Das ist ja Failchamp.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Der will mich refragen, der will mich refragen.
Ich sag's euch, wir müssen jetzt hier ab aimen.
Typischer Battlefield Kill.
Killen uns gegenseitig, aber sind genug Teammates da, die mich sollten mich eigentlich haben.
Hoffe ich mal.
Habt ihr mich? Teammates?
Ah, nice. Exzellent.
Okay.
Wir falten jetzt nicht hier, wir gehen ins Haus.
Wobei, hier in die Hütte müssen wir nicht.
Wir müssen da hinten in die Hütte, hier in die Hütte müssen wir.
Exzellent, beste, beste Posi.
Sache ist nur die, die entkommen, sind schon alle gelegt.
Das hier ist beste, beste Posi hier.
Da kamen die richtig schön rein.
Baschen.
Wollte man das nicht aufsprengen?
Also man muss ehrlich sagen, wir gehen hier grad ganz schön durch.
Die Gegner können nicht allzu viel machen.
Gucken wir mal da hinten.
Ich hol dich, ich hol dich.
Da unten ist irgendein Typ.
Okay, das ist mega random gerade alles.
Da oben war einer, ich hab ihn gesehen eben.
Es ist weg.
Das ist fucking random, ey.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Lass mich in Ruhe, Leute.
In the ass schon wieder.
30-3.
Was geht mit dem Kerl ab?
30-3, was hat der gemacht?
Was eine Hit-Registration, ey.
Hit, Hit-Register-Off-Doom.
Guckt euch das an.
Yolo, Yolo-Modus.
Fertig, ich rette dich.
Yolo-Modus.
Easy, easy, Yolo-Modus.
Aber by the way, die Noobs gehen rechts hoch.
Am besten geht man hier hoch.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Nein.
Hier ist eigentlich viel besser.
Da kann man nämlich reinbashing, ohne dass es checken.
Erst mal gucken, was hier abgeht.
Okay, da haben wir gelegt.
Da ist die Legehänne am Start.
Jawoll.
Wo ist die nächste Legehänne?
Legehänne.
Extreme Legehänne.
Nein.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Garda-Exe.
Besser wäre Brain-Exe, Alter.
So, weiter.
Erst mal random geflamed einfach.
Nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Survive-Champ.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, der hat gerade 50 Milliarden Kills gemacht.
Mit seinem C4.
Es ist so krass random gerade.
Es ist so übertrieben random.
What the fuck?
Es ist so übertrieben random gerade.
Aber ganz einfach abgedeckt.
Viel zu wenig Tickets.
Viel, viel zu wenig Tickets.
Okay, Leute.
Nice, dass ihr dabei wart.
Easy clap.
Ich geh was futtern.
Ich hab mega Hunger.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
War extrem nice.
Mal gucken, wie lang die Noob-Welle mit Battlefield noch anhält.
Also bis dann, macht's gut.
CU.